Dumme Facebook-Stuff. Warum seid ihr hier, wassert eure Zeit? Wir sollen auf Video-Games spielen. Stan, du weißt nicht, wie cool Facebook ist. Du kannst deine Freunde messen, mit deinen Freunden Yatzee spielen, sogar deinen eigenen Virtual-Farm starten und deine Freunde besuchen.
Ja, Dude, wir machen dir deine eigene Facebook-Page.
Nein, ich habe euch gesagt, ich will nicht auf Facebook sein. Ja, aber jetzt könnt ihr alle Freunde mitnehmen. Ich will nicht in das Ding kommen.
Ihr seid vertraut, ich spiele Xbox.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 178. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und die heutige Ausgabe wendet sich mal wieder einem gesellschaftlichen Thema zu. Auch das muss sein und auch das hat alles wie immer Bezug auch zur Technologie. Ja, etwas schwer für mich am Anfang zu umreißen, worum es eigentlich genau gehen wird, aber im weiteren Sinne wollen wir hier sprechen über Jugendliche, Kinder, Mediencomputer, Medienkompetenz, all das, Jugendarbeit im weiteren Sinne, da wo es vor allem die Technologien betrifft, die uns täglich so alle umgeben. Und dazu begrüße ich Bernd, Bernd Dörr, hallo. Willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. Ja, du steckst ein bisschen in dem Thema drin, kann man sagen.
Oh ja, kann man schon sagen, ich stecke ein bisschen in dem Thema drin. Also ich habe die letzten sieben Jahre das Medienkompetenzzentrum Schlottenburg-Wilmersdorf hier in Berlin geleitet. Das heißt, ich komme aus der offenen Kinder- und Jugendarbeit. Offen heißt in dem Moment, die Tür ist ab Nachmittags nach der Schule für alle Kinder offen und dort habe ich den Computerbereich betreut, die Netzwerke aufgebaut, Computer-Schulungen gemacht. Und alles, was damit zusammenhängt, organisiert, Projekte vor allem, praktische Medienprojekte.
Wer betreibt dieses Zentrum? Wem gehört das? Wer baut das auf? Wer zahlt das?
Das Zentrum ist eine Einrichtung von Jugendnetz Berlin. Die haben vor acht Jahren ein Programm gestartet. Also Jugendnetz Berlin gibt es in diesem Jahr zum zehnten. Die haben jetzt ein Jubiläum. Und zwar gab es die Initiative des Senats, zu sagen, wir wollen die Medienkompetenz in Berlin fördern, in den Bezirken. Es gab hier immer schon Einrichtungen, die mit Computern gearbeitet haben. Die haben diese selber angeschafft, die haben selber Projekte entwickelt, wie man Kindern beibringen kann, was funktioniert an dem Ding, wie funktioniert es, wie wende ich Programme an, was kann ich vor allem kreativ damit machen? Aus pädagogischer Hinsicht kreativ. Also Bildbearbeitung, Audio-Dateien bearbeiten, Fotos, Fotostories entwickeln und so weiter. Das Jugendnetz Berlin Programm wurde aufgestellt, um diese Initiativen finanziell zu unterstützen. Und daraufhin wurde vom Senat eine große Menge Geld bereitgestellt. Jedes Mal konnte man sich, also jeder Bezirk konnte sich in einer Einrichtung als Medienkompetenzzentrum bewerben. Deshalb gibt es nur zwölf. Obwohl es mehr Einrichtungen gibt, die mit Computern arbeiten, die konnten sich als sogenannte Jugendinfo Points bewerben. Dann gab es eine Hardware-Ausstattung, womit man praktisch erstmal loslegen konnte, also Geld zum Einkaufen. Dieses Medienkompetenzzentrum sollte in einer Kinder- und Jugendeinrichtung sein, also deshalb sind die auch alle in Kinder- und Jugendeinrichtungen völlig unterschiedlicher Trägerstruktur. Also es gibt kein zweites MECO, Medienkompetenzzentrum als Abkürzung, das die gleiche Trägerstruktur hat. Entweder die Einrichtung, in der es beheimatet ist, ist in freier Trägerschaft, oder also inzwischen immer mehr, in bezirklicher kommunaler Trägerschaft oder eine Mischform oder wie auch immer. Und diese Arbeit ist Berlin-übergreifend. Es gibt auch einmal im Monat einen sogenannten Beirat. Da haben die Medienkompetenzzentren, wie gesagt, Beratenden oder Beiratenden, ja, also wie sagt man das?
Beratende Tätigkeit?
Tätigkeit, genau. Tätigkeit. Die Entscheidungen, die dort getroffen werden, werden auch meistens finanziert, sodass man über seine Arbeit so ein bisschen selber bestimmen kann. Also die Projekte, die man starten will, da braucht man dann öfters auch mal wieder eine neue Ausstattung oder eine Videokamera oder ein Software. Das kann man dort dann beantragen. Dann gibt es Förderprogramme in themengebundenen Bereichen, zum Beispiel zur Fußballweltmeisterschaft 2006 gab es Cyberkicker. Dort konnte man Radiosendungen aufnehmen. Es gab Fernsehprogramme, die man selber gestalten konnte, mit Kindern und Jugendlichen zusammen. Und wenn da die Ausstattung fehlte oder wenn da Honorarkräfte fehlten, hat das Jugendnetz noch beigesteuert. So das ist so das Prinzip.
Bevor wir jetzt vielleicht zu tief in die konkreten Strukturen eintauchen, will ich erstmal noch mal so ein bisschen deinen Hintergrund noch so ein bisschen hinterfragen. Du wirst ja auch einen gewissen Weg genommen haben, bis du dann dort gelandet bist. Was sind denn das so für Karrieren, die man da beschreitet, bis man in dem Teil arbeitet? Warst du schon immer so in dem erzieherischen Bereich?
Also im erzieherischen Bereich ja. Also ursprünglich selber mal eine Tätigkeit als Erzieher angefangen, dann Diplomierte Sozialpädagoge, Sozialarbeiter hier gemacht und in der Jugendarbeit in sehr weit vorne Bereich angesteuert, den es damals so in diesem Sinne gar nicht gab. Und dann in den Multimedia-Bereich, die es damals hier noch eingesteuert, Programmierung von Lernprogrammen und Webseitengestaltung, alles Mögliche. Später dann auch noch mal eine Ausbildung gemacht zum Datenbank- und Softwareprogrammierer. Die Schienen liefen dann selbstständig nicht so wahnsinnig glücklich, sodass ich mich dann umgeschaut habe, ob es die sozialpädagogische mit der multimedialen Schiene irgendwie zu verbinden gilt. Das habe ich dort in dieser Kinder- und Jugendanrichtung gefunden, wo ich am Anfang mit einer Kollegin noch den Computerraum betreut habe, mit insgesamt sechs Arbeitsplätzen, oder sechs Plätzen, sind ja keine Arbeitsplätze, sind ja Freizeitplätze, sechs Computer und später dann umgezogen bin und auf acht Windows und fünf Linux-Rechner aufgestockt habe. Dann aber leider Gottes alleine.
Was lernt man denn eigentlich so als Sozialpädagoge?
Als Sozialpädagoge bieten die Fachhochschulen, die sie jetzt hier fast alle Hochschulen nennen in Berlin, das ganze Spektrum von...
Ist das eine reine Hochschulausbildung? Also ist das nur Fachhochschulen?
Nee, das gibt es in den Hochschulen und Fachhochschulen oder auch Universitären. Da unterscheidet sich auch der Abschluss. Fachhochschulabschlüsse sind keine akademischen Abschlüsse und nur die universitären, obwohl man auch Sozialpädagoge ist, ist dann ein akademischer Abschluss. Das kann man auch in Klammern bei der Berufsbezeichnung hinten dran angeben.
Aber man lernt ja jetzt auch nichts anderes als an den Hochschulen?
Doch, doch. Also man lernt schon was anderes, weil die universitäre Ausbildung wesentlich theoretischer ist. Es gibt zwar Praktika, aber weniger. Es wird auch weniger in die Praxis zurückgekoppelt, sondern es geht eher um theoretische Entwürfe. Im Endeffekt spielt das bei der Berufsbezeichnung als Sozialpädagogentitel keine Rolle, aber in der Einstufung und auch vor allem in den Möglichkeiten, mit diesem Abschluss auf universitärer Ebene sich weiterzubilden. Das hat man mit der Fachhochschulebene leider Gottes nicht. Insofern der Bologna-Prozess irgendwann mal weitergegangen sein sollte, wäre das ein Ziel, diese beiden Abschlüsse relativ zu vereinen, sodass man direkt mit dem Fachhochschule-Abschluss, der jetzt ja auch nur noch Hochschulabschluss heißt, auch auf Uniebene weitermachen zu können. Was immer mehr geht, aber noch nicht ganz durchgedrungen ist. Und vor allem die älteren Abschlüsse, wo es halt wirklich noch strikt getrennt war, bedeuten finanziell ganz entscheidend andere Eingruppierungen und andere Karrierechancen, whatever.
Aber ich meine, wo taucht man da ein? Was für eine Welt, wenn man so eine Ausbildung macht? Was wird einem da so nahe gelegt? Was lernt man eigentlich jetzt? Was kriegt man da wirklich für ein Risszeug mit, mit dem man später arbeiten kann? Ich meine, das ist so ein Begriff, da kann man sich immer so relativ wenig drunter… Ich meine, klar, ich kann jetzt sagen, okay, Pädagoge, das ist halt irgendwie einer, der so die Erziehung an andere heranträgt. Und dann ist es jetzt auch noch sozial. Okay, hurra. Was macht das aus?
Was steckt da so drin? Das ist auch vielleicht noch ein bisschen in Kontrast zu dem Erzieher, der sich jetzt wirklich nur mit der Tätigkeit mit Kindern oder Jugendlichen beschäftigt, anzusehen, weil es auch möglich ist, als Sozialpädagoge Einrichtungen zu leiten. Das kann man als Erzieher auch. Aber das Rüstzeug betrifft als Sozialpädago in der Ausbildung eher auch noch die rechtlichen Fragen, die in der Erzieherinnen-Ausbildung auch angesprochen werden, aber nicht so den Schwerpunkt haben. Das heißt, man wird auch darauf vorbereitet, sowohl auf dem Jugendamt später zu arbeiten, um ambulante Hilfen vorzubereiten oder auch in der Straßensezialarbeit zu arbeiten oder in Kinder- und Jugendheimen, auch in Kinder- und Jugendeinrichtungen natürlich, aber auch im Pflegedienst, im Krankenbereich. Also das ist ein sehr weit gestreutes Gebiet, wo man als Sozialpädagogin oder Pädago eingesetzt werden kann.
Aber jetzt unabhängig von den potenziellen Berufschancen, die das jetzt so macht. Meine Frage zielte mir so auf dieses, was atmet man da, wenn man da sich so eine Ausbildung eingibt. Was wird so an einen herangetragen? Was für eine Kompetenz entsteht da in einem? Lernt man da, die Menschen zu verstehen? Lernt man da, die Probleme zu verstehen? Kriegt man da Handlungsanweisen oder kriegt man einfach so ein Gefühl für andere Menschen? Was ist das für eine Ausbildung? Was ist das für ein Ding?
Also ich muss zugeben, du erwischst mich da ein bisschen auf dem linken Fuß, weil die Ausbildung schon relativ weit weg ist und meine Schwerpunkte in den letzten zehn Jahren einfach sehr anders gewesen sind. Die Ausbildung fand ich im Rückblick super. Das hängt aber auch damit zusammen, inwiefern man sich auf so einen Entwicklungsprozess während dieser drei, vier Jahre einlässt. Es gibt natürlich sehr viel Einblicke in Lebenswelten von Kindern, von Erwachsenen oder auch von alten Leuten. Dazu theoretisches Rüstzeug, wie Erziehung abläuft, wie Entwicklungen ablaufen, welche Theoretiker, zu welchen Entwicklungsstadien, vor allem bei Kindern, gesagt haben, was da also praktisch möglich ist und was nicht möglich ist. Das ist schon so ein theoretischer Background, der relativ umfassend ist und einem durchaus auch hilft, in der praktischen Arbeit nachher klarzukommen. Als Hintergrund wirklich.
Weil man so ein Gefühl hat für die Phasen und für die Umbrüche.
Es bleibt ja von dem theoretischen Wissen, dass man sich irgendwann mal durch diese Unterrichtsstunden und Seminare angeeignet hat, nicht mehr so konkret was übrig, sondern eher so dieses, wie gesagt, Gefühl für diese Menschen. Das Engagement ist immer auf Pro gestimmt, würde ich mal sagen, um Entwicklungspotenziale herauszufinden und Menschen in verschiedenen Situationen gezielt fördern zu können.
Was meinst du damit auf Pro gestimmt?
Menschen in Situationen, die zum Jugendamt kommen oder so was, in schwierigen Erziehungssituationen zum Beispiel, da Hilfestellungen an die Hand geben zu können. Hilfeorientiert. Leider Gott, das sehr oft noch defizitorientiert. Also wo ist ein Problem? Das versuchen wir zu behandeln, anstatt so den ganzen Lebensentwurf zu behandeln. Das betrifft dann wieder andere gesellschaftliche Fragen, die man in der Ausbildung und auch nicht auf dem Arbeitsplatz aushandeln kann. Das sind dann auch politische Fragen, warum Menschen in so eine Situation überhaupt reinkommen.
Jetzt heißt es ja, wenn man Sozialpädagogin, man heißt zwangsläufig, dass man sich da mit Jugendlichen auseinandersetzt? Nö, eigentlich nicht. Also schon so eine Spezialisierung, die man sich dann irgendwie auch...
Genau, also man sucht sich das im Endeffekt aus, vor allem in den Hauptstudiengängen, in den Abschlussseminaren legt man dann auch seine eigenen Schwerpunkte auf entweder Kinder, Jugendliche, alte Menschen, Pflegebedürftige, das geht nach seinen eigenen Interessen und die richten sich natürlich danach, was man später arbeiten möchte oder wo man sich bewerben möchte, was so sein eigenes Ding ist.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, hast du so eine technische Neigung, die du hier sicherlich mit vielen Hörern teilst, aber eben auch so diesen erzieherischen, ich nenne es jetzt mal erzieherischen, sozialpädagogischen Hintergrund, das ist auch das Feld, in dem du arbeiten wolltest und dann war sozusagen, also in welchem Jahr war das jetzt so, wo sich sozusagen da für dich so der Weg geschieht oder wiederum zusammengeführt hat, also wo das sozusagen anstand, das zusammenzubringen? Und in welchem Zeitraum reden wir jetzt?
Also die reine Sozialpädagogik, da hatte ich auch noch andere Perspektiven mit, die hatte ich relativ 98 im letzten Jahrhundert sozusagen verabschiedet. Und dann auch mit Multimedia-Ausbildung angefangen. Wie gesagt, diese CBT-Programmierung oder auch Webseitengestaltung und solche Sachen.
Ja, also wir reden jetzt sozusagen von Anfang 2000, wo das dann für dich quasi ein Thema wurde. Also so ein Zeitpunkt, wo Internet im Prinzip schon da war, sich also mehr als nur abgezeichnet hat und ja auch Computer schon richtig eine Verbreitung hatten. Und was war dann so deine Erkenntnis? Also ich meine, was macht sozusagen die Realität aus?
Wie meinst du das?
Naja, Jugendliche und Internet und so. Auf was bist du da gestoßen? Was ist sozusagen da die Realität gewesen? Finden das alle super interessant? Interessieren die sich überhaupt nicht dafür?
Also du meinst aber jetzt auch schon die Verschränkung von Sozialarbeit und dieser Medienschule?
Naja, ich meine, du hast ja, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, du hast ja gesagt, okay, ich versuche jetzt mal eine technische Linie einzuschlagen. Und dann hast du dich aber eher entschlossen, das wieder zusammenzuführen und sozusagen so eine konkrete Arbeit zu machen, die dann letztendlich derzeit sich in diesem Jugendmedien-Kompetenzzentrum zusammenführt. Also, wer kommt dahin, auf wen stößt man, auf welche Jugendlichen stößt man, wie alt sind die, wer ist da?
Also das ist am Anfang in der Einrichtung, in der ich angefangen habe, unterschieden gewesen. Diese Einrichtungen haben einfach erstmal einen Freizeitaspekt, Freizeitschwerpunkt, da kommen die Jugendlichen nach der Schule hin. Und das hat sich in den letzten sieben, acht Jahren halt deutlich auch geändert mit der Einführung der Ganztagsgrundschule. Früher war die Altersgruppe auch eine völlig andere in der Einrichtung, in der ich gearbeitet habe. Und das betrifft andere Einrichtungen auch. Das heißt, es wird nie, es bleibt nie gleich. Also, Ältere kommen mal rein, klickenweise meistens, besetzen sozusagen eher das Haus. Das ist dann so ihre Freizeithütte so ungefähr. Dann wachsen die da aus diesen ganzen Bezügen raus. Und Jüngere rücken nach. Und was gesellschaftlich und auch mit dem Netz passiert, das lässt sich ein bisschen auch ablesen an dem, was die an Motivation und an Interessen mitbringen. Als ich angefangen habe, war das ganz oft, na, es gibt einen Computerraum, das ist toll, da gehen wir hin, schalten die Lautsprecher auf 10 und knallen Radio Energy rein. Und zwar von drei, vier Rechnern gleichzeitig. Das war toll. Das hatte so diesen Party-Aspekt und vor allem ist es eine Unterhaltungsmaschine. Also es war von uns Erzieherinnen und Sozialpädagoginnen eher dann das steuernde Element zu sagen, wir versuchen hier auch ein bisschen was an Bildung reinzukriegen und versuchen, Projekte aufzubauen. Das heißt, nicht nur konsumieren, sondern produzieren. Sich ausdenken, was man mit den Kindern und Jugendlichen, mit den Programmen, die wir zur Verfügung haben, anstellen kann. Und das war relativ wenig. Also die ganze Ausstattung, die Hardware war relativ, also nicht so am neuesten Stand, weil das prinzipielle Problem in allen Einrichtungen, egal in welcher Trägerschaft, darin besteht, dass sie keine Finanzmittel haben oder wenig Finanzmittel für diese Zwecke auch von den Bezirksämtern bekommen. Und wenn, dann dauert das ewig lange. Bis dahin ist die Generation an Rechnern, die man beantragt hat, auch schon wiederveraltet und so weiter. Das trägt sich durch die Jahre fort. Das heißt, wir haben die einerseits natürlich ihre eigenen Interessen entwickeln lassen und Bilder suchen. YouTube war damals auch noch nicht so wahnsinnig bekannt. Irgendwelche Filme oder sonst irgendwas suchen lassen und aber auch versucht, die in Projekte reinzukriegen und gleichzeitig versucht, diese Projekte überhaupt Hardware- oder Software-technisch zu ermöglichen, indem wir geguckt haben, wo können wir Programme herkriegen, wie können wir die über die Bezirksamts- oder Jugendnetz-Strukturen finanzieren, wie können wir Hardware herankriegen, wo gibt es Institutionen, Versicherungen, Banken, wer auch immer, die uns Geräte spenden für die Kinder- und Jugendarbeit, da gibt es durchaus Bereitschaften. Das heißt, man muss so ein bisschen managen, um den Boden für Projekte überhaupt erst bereitstellen zu können. Und das war der Schwerpunkt, zu sagen, wir machen mit den Computern was anderes, als jetzt nur Internetseiten aufzurufen, uns über Witze schlapp zu lachen oder Fotos zu suchen. Sondern wir machen Fotostories, wir machen kleine Videoclips, wir versuchen die zu schneiden am Rechner und machen da ein Projekt raus. Wir machen Stadterkundungsprojekte, solche Sachen.
Um sich nochmal die Situation besser vorstellen zu können, also wer kommt dahin? Welches Alter?
Wie viele? Das hängt von der Größe der Einrichtung ab.
Bleiben wir mal bei dem Beispiel von deinem Schalottenbuch.
Also, Alter ist ab acht Jahre aufwärts, dass sie in den Computerraum kommen. Ansonsten sind auch Gruppenangebote unter acht Jahren schon im Haus. Das heißt, Jonglagegruppen zum Beispiel oder Artistikgruppen, die sind natürlich auch mit Kindern unter acht Jahren schon besetzt. In den Computerraum gab es eine hausinterne Regelung, kommen die Kinder erst ab acht Jahren rein. Deshalb war auch der Nachmittagsbereich für die Jüngeren bis zum frühen Abend präserviert. Das heißt, acht bis zwölf, dreizehn, vierzehn Jahre. Und im Abendbereich kommen dann die 14-, 15-, 16-, 17-, 18-Jährigen, insofern die 18-, 19-Jährigen überhaupt noch in die Hütte kommen.
In welchen Mengen kommen die dann so?
Das hat sich in allen Einrichtungen eigentlich sehr stark verändert, darüber, dass die Schulstrukturen anders sind und die Besuchergruppen immer wieder sich ändern. Also im Jahr gibt es da meistens einen Durchlauf, sodass die Älteren praktisch rauswachsen und die Jüngeren nachkommen, insofern es Jüngere gibt. Und in den letzten Jahren hat sich eigentlich so ein Besucherschwund auch herausgestellt, aber in allen Einrichtungen.
Ja, aber wie viele sind so vor Ort?
20, 50, 80. Also es...
Gleichzeitig.
Gleichzeitig waren am Anfang...
80....
in dieser Einrichtung, da war die Hütte voll. 80. Das ist eine Rieseneinrichtung mindestens.
Gleichzeitig. Krass.
Das ist teilweise noch wenig gewesen. Wir hatten Veranstaltungen, da standen 400 bis 450 da. Weil das in dem Haus, wo ich war...
Also wir reden jetzt über so einen normalen Wochentag, Schule ist vorbei. Wie viel Uhr geht es dann los?
Also normalerweise in der Einrichtung, in der ich war, nachmittags um drei.
Nachmittags um drei und dann macht es Palim Palim und dann kommen sie alle reingelatscht.
Also wie gesagt, nachmittags in unserem Haus, damals bis zum frühen Abend die Jüngeren bis 14 Jahre und das möchten dann 30, 40, 50 im Durchlauf gewesen sein und abends dann halt die älteren Jugendlichen. Es gibt teilweise Gruppenangebote, die sie interessieren, wie zum Beispiel Breakdancen, die beiden Termine, wo Breakdancer in der großen Halle üben.
Du redest sozusagen von der gesamten Einrichtung, nicht nur jetzt von dem Medien-Teil?
Ich rede natürlich nicht nur von dem Medien-Teil, weil ich als Medien-Teil natürlich auch nur ein Teil des ganzen Hauses war und das Konzept war, wir integrieren das alles.
Okay. Aber trotzdem, aber wie viele kommen dann sozusagen davon konkret, wie viel setzen sich mit Medien, mit Arbeit, mit Computern, Netz, Software etc. auseinander?
Also die Zahlen sind da natürlich deutlich niedriger, weil das ein Raum ist, der nicht mehr als 15, 14 Arbeitsplätze hat.
Ich würde nur eine Vorstellung dafür bekommen, wie groß muss man sich das vorstellen?
Also das waren Nachmittags 20, 30, 40 Kinder, die da innerhalb dieser 3, 4, 5 Stunden aufgelaufen sind, reingekommen sind, vielleicht eine halbe Stunde oder eine Stunde blieben, wieder rausgegangen sind. Und abends dementsprechend dann auch plus minus 30. Also 9 oder 10 wieder Schluss waren.
Und was treibt die da hin? Warum kommen die da hin?
Ja, was treibt die da hin? Das war am Anfang eher so dieses, ich interessiere mich für Computer bzw. was macht das Ding, was kann das überhaupt, was kann ich damit anstellen?
Das heißt, die haben auch keinen?
Die haben am Anfang in den Umgebungen, und da kommen sie meistens sehr direkt aus der Laufkundschaft sozusagen, wenig Computer gehabt. Genau das ist der Punkt, warum es dann in den letzten Jahren weniger wurde, weil immer mehr zu Hause angeschafft wurden. Die mussten dieses Medium wirklich neu kennenlernen. Fernseher gab es, Radio gab es, Walkman MP3-Player gab es. Aber Computer, die waren damals einfach noch ein bisschen zu teuer. Auch für sozial schwächere Familien. Die sind dann auch größtenteils in die Einrichtung gekommen, haben sich dieses Gerät angeguckt, haben gesagt, ich will mal wissen, was man damit machen kann. Und das war auch dann so mein Einstieg in die Medienpädagogik. Gibt es hier Möglichkeiten zu lernen, was ich sinnvollerweise mit dem Ding machen kann? Oder gibt es die Möglichkeiten für meine Kinder, dass die lernen, nicht nur hier ruft man eine Internetadresse auf, sondern was macht man damit? Wie kann man sich im Internet schützen? Was gibt es für Gefahren? Was gibt es für Möglichkeiten? Was gibt es für Ideen, wie man ohne Internet Projekte machen kann? Das war so der Beginn der Computerführerscheine, der Computerkurse für Kinder.
Und muss man die Kinder da eher, ist es mehr ein Beschützen oder ist es mehr ein Heranführen?
Ups, ja, das ist so die Frage zwischen Bewahrpädagogik und im Moment ist es eher so die Frage, nicht die Frage, sondern eher die Option zu begleiten. Es war früher eher das Thema, sie möchten alles ausprobieren und wie wende ich es an? Das heißt, man konnte ihnen eher so diesen Aspekt, was kann ich tun und wie muss ich es anstellen, vermitteln. Inzwischen kennen die sich unheimlich gut aus. Es gibt durchaus auch mehr Schulen, die Computer haben. Es gibt mehr Familien, die Computer haben. Das heißt, diese pure Gebrauchshaptik ist nicht mehr unbedingt nötig zu vermitteln, sondern was machen die Kinder inzwischen dort, auch in den sozialen Netzwerken, und wie kann ich sie darin begleiten? Weil die Grundbegriffe, die kennen sie. Das hat sich in den Computerkursen dahingehend ausgewirkt. Am Anfang fragte ich, wir machen jetzt hier Textverarbeitung, Bildbearbeitung und ganz, ganz viel Internet, weil das ist ja so toll und interessant. Wer hat denn schon mal Text geschrieben? Meldeten sich aus einer 15er-Gruppe 2.3. Bildbearbeitung, ja, Bild gemalt schon wesentlich mehr. Im Internet war am Anfang aus diesen Computerkursen für Kinder. Und ich rede jetzt von acht bis zwölf, 13 Jahren niemand oder zwei. Inzwischen gehen da fast alle Finger hoch, weil das kennen sie. So, und dann muss ich anders arbeiten. Am Anfang war das wirklich, ja, ich bringe ihnen was bei. Wie kann ich irgendwas herstellen? Was gibt es da? Das war das unbekannte Medium. War wirklich so eine unbekannte Blackbox, die irgendwas macht. Inzwischen ist es halt über die Gewöhnung in Elternhausen, Schule eher. Die haben was rausgefunden. Die kriegen über die Schulhöfe, die kriegen über die Peers, die kriegen über ihre Bekanntschaften auch in den Netzwerken Tipps und probieren das aus. Haben sie aber den Reflexionsraum mitzukriegen, was sie da eigentlich machen? Und inwiefern geben sie, wie in den Netzwerken, ihre Daten freiwilligerweise viel zu weitläufig raus? Also sie sind schon drin und es geht eher darum, mit ihnen zusammen da mitzugehen.
Wofür interessieren die sich mehr? Interessieren die sich mehr für den Computer oder mehr für die Kommunikation? Also ist es mehr so, dass Internet und die Möglichkeiten und der Computer ist nur das Mittel zum Zweck und interessiert eigentlich gar nicht? Oder ist es wirklich auch so, die Rechenmaschine mit ihren Anwendungsmöglichkeiten auch unabhängig vom Netz? Spielt das noch beides dieselbe Rolle? Oder hat sich das jetzt komplett in Richtung Netz verschoben? Oder vielleicht auch gar nicht?
Es hat sich komplett in Richtung Netz verschoben. Also die Frage, wie funktioniert das Ding überhaupt, das ich hier benutze, das ist ja auch runtergebrochen, immer das Ding Kind sitzt davor, macht irgendwas und es funktioniert nicht. Der Ansatzpunkt war dann immer zu sagen, was hast du gemacht? Was kannst du ansonsten vielleicht anstellen, um dein Ziel zu erreichen? Dieses Gerät anderen für sich interessiert sehr wenig. Und das hat nicht zugenommen, das ist gleich geblieben. Dieser Prozentsatz von 0,2 ist meinetwegen fiktiv, aber relativ real, wenn ich mir die Computer-Kurse angucke und mir angucke, was die Kinder und Jugendlichen tagsüber in den Computerräumen machen. Das Gerät interessiert wenig, es interessiert, dass es läuft, dass es schnell läuft und dass es alles macht, was gemacht werden soll. Also Internetseiten müssen schnell kommen, Flash-Filme müssen schnell kommen, YouTube muss schnell ablaufen, das soziale Netzwerk muss mit zwei, drei Tabs gleichzeitig machbar sein. Und warum es manchmal nicht funktioniert oder warum das auch von der Hardware abhängt, das ist so eine Ebene, die muss man geschickt einpflegen. Ansonsten ist das Verständnis nicht von alleine da, dass es Sachen gibt, die jetzt nicht einfach so per se funktionieren. Da ist die Vorstellung vielleicht eher noch so in Richtung Zauberbox. Ich setze mich davor, sage irgendwas und es funktioniert. Das funktioniert halt eben gar nicht. Und das war auch der Grund für mich, zum Beispiel in den Computerkursen, am Anfang immer zu sagen, wir machen die erste Einheit Hardware. Wir machen so ein Ding auf, gucken rein und reden darüber und erklären, wie das funktioniert. Und das entzaubert sehr viel. Es ist nämlich keine Blackbox, es gibt Kabel, es gibt Strom, es gibt ganz mechanische Unfälle dabei, es gibt den Stromschalter, den man nicht nach Belieben fünfmal an- und ausschalten darf, das Gerät dann irgendwann Pieps macht und das war's. Das war aber immer so das Zugeständnis, dass sie an mich als Seminaleiter dann gegeben haben, wir lassen uns das jetzt erst mal erzählen. Und dann kommen wir aber zu den Praktischen, sagen.
Dürfen wir jetzt endlich Facebook machen?
Ja, und dann hieß es, wann machen wir denn was? Und dann habe ich gesagt, wir machen schon was, wir haben schon längst angefangen. Wir reden seit zwei Stunden jetzt hier über die Kiste. Also komischerweise, und das hat mich ermudigt, immer in dieser Schiene weiterzumachen, hat es funktioniert. Erstens konnten sie sich am nächsten Tag noch an die Sachen erinnern, die Hardware betreffen, auch an die Funktionsweise. Und ich hatte immer so das Gefühl, okay, ein bisschen was von diesem Grundsätzlichen. Ich bin ja auch nicht sehr weit gegangen. Wäre ja auch Blödsinn gewesen im Alter von 8 bis 12, 13 Jahren. Aber es hat etwas an Grundverständnis vermittelt. Und da kann man dann auch wieder anknüpfen. Es gab immer den Punkt Impulse schaffen. Also wirklich so Themen an-triggern und die dann auch weiterlaufen lassen. Sie werden irgendwann mal aufgegriffen. Vielleicht werden sie aber auch gar nicht wieder aufgegriffen. Zumindest gab es einfach auch mal diesen Horizont, dieses Thema Hardware, dieses Thema Stromkasten oder dieses Thema Motherboard. Das gab es mal. So, ah, da kann ich mich erinnern. Irgendwo war da mal was. Wenn das übrig geblieben ist, das reicht mir schon. Dann muss man sich nicht perfekt merken, welche Taktraten und wie das mit den Rams einzusetzen ist oder welche Mutationen es bei Overclocking sonst wo hingeht. Das ist gar nicht wichtig. Es geht darum, so einen prinzipiellen Blick mal drauf zu werfen. Den habe ich so ein bisschen immer beipulen müssen, aber es hat funktioniert.
Ist die Wissbegier, die man sich vielleicht erhoffen möchte, auch da?
In dem Punkt war sie komischerweise da. Hätte ich vorher gesagt, wir machen jetzt Hardware, das ist das und das, dann wäre wahrscheinlich der ganze Kurs abgestürzt und gesagt, wir schalten jetzt eine halbe Stunde oder zwei auf Standby und danach fahren wir uns wieder hoch, weil dann können wir endlich was machen. Es war komischerweise interessant für die und ich denke, es ist ja auch interessant, sich so viel mal anzugucken.
Aber schon mit dem einigen Versprechen, jetzt gibt es hier gleich Netz, aber bevor wir dahin kommen, müssen wir ja erst mal durch das CD-Rom-Laufwerk kriechen.
Ja, also es gab Anwendungsprogramme und dann gab es Netz. Also es gibt auch so eine Entwicklung, wie gesagt, von Hardware zu Offline zu Online. Und dieser Entwicklungsweg, deshalb ist dieses Curriculum des Computerführerscheins, das entwickelt wurde in den Kindernjugendeinrichtungen, übergreifend, hat auch funktioniert und trägt auch immer noch. Das funktioniert.
Wie ändert sich das so mit dem Alter?
Das ändert sich dahingehend, also auch mit den Jahren inzwischen, dass auch die Jüngeren teilweise, da war ich wirklich überrascht, in den vierten Klassen in Netzwerken unterwegs sind, also eher in Schülervorzeit. Und auch in den fünften und sechsten Klassen Web 2.0-Tools wie Blocks nicht unbekannt waren. Die werden teilweise an der Schule geführt, teilweise haben, also es waren wirklich dann sozusagen Ausreißer, in Anführungszeichen, Kinder drei, vier Blocks geführt, naja, also mehr oder weniger geführt, die hatten sie angelegt. Das heißt, die Kompetenz, da durch zu navigieren, mit den Daten und den Services klarzukommen, hatten sie dann schon sich selber angeeignet. Andere hingegen gar nicht, das war der Großteil. Sonst bräuchte ich Kurse ja auch irgendwann gar nicht mehr machen. Aber immer mehr gab es auch Kinder, die im Alter von 10 ganz genau gewusst haben, wo sie hinmüssen oder auch Workshops, die ich gemacht habe, mit fünften, sechsten Klassen, wenn es darum geht. Wir machen eine Internetseite, Themen gebunden, zum Beispiel zu Handys oder zu den Filmen, die man mit Handys machen kann. Oder auch von der Schule vorgegeben, Gewalt an Schulen und so weiter. Und sucht euch da Material aus dem Netz raus. Die waren teilweise, also sagen wir mal ein Drittel war da sehr schnell. Die wussten, sie gehen zu Flickr, zu Google und sonst wohin. Und ein Großteil saß da so, wie fange ich es an? Also diese Schere gibt es in den Klassen. Zum Glück ist die nicht sehr groß und die vermitteln sich ja freiwillig ihre Wissensvorsprünge gegenseitig. Also das ist ein Peer-to-Peer-Lernen, was da funktioniert.
Gibt es dann auch Jugendliche, die das alles überhaupt nicht interessiert?
Ja, also inzwischen gibt es durchaus welche, die sagen auch ich habe überhaupt keine Lust auf Internet und diesen ganzen Mailing-Kram, das ist mir viel zu viel und mit Netzwerken habe ich nichts zu tun, weil ich will weder, dass ein Bild von mir veröffentlicht wird, noch dass irgendjemand meine Daten da rausholen kann. Das ist aber sehr neu und es ist sehr wenig. Die meisten sind irgendwo drin und zwar in zwei oder drei Netzwerken oder auch in Chat-Programmen kommen, wie man muss es halt sagen, MSN.
Das ist jetzt auch für mich ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz einfach, ich meine, ich habe jetzt mich das jetzt so zu entwickeln, weil ich habe ja nun selber, das trifft wahrscheinlich auch auf viele, wenn auch nicht alle, der Hörer zu, immer so ein Grundinteresse gehabt. Also mich hat immer so die Maschine interessiert, mich hat vor allem immer total geärgert, wenn ich nicht wirklich vollständig verstanden habe, warum irgendwas so ist, wie es ist. Ich denke, das ist so ein bisschen auch so ein Hackerinstinkt, dass man sich irgendwie so ein bisschen schlecht fühlt, wenn man irgendwas benutzt und man versteht in dem Moment gar nicht, was man da benutzt. Also so bis ins letzte Detail eigentlich und so auch gar nicht nur auf Computer bezogen, sondern eigentlich alles auf diesem Planeten, dass immer, wenn man eben vor dieser Zauberbox sitzt, dass einen dann so irgendwas im Nacken kneift, was dann irgendwie sagt so, du weißt gar nicht, was du da tust, ja, und dann fühlt man sich irgendwie schlecht. Wie groß würdest du so den Prozentanteil taxieren von Kids, denen es irgendwie so geht?
Minimal.
Der Hackerquotient.
Der Hackerquotient, würde ich mal sagen, liegt unter Null.
Unter Null? Das ist ja ein negativer Bereich. Das kann nicht sein.
Das kann nicht sein, richtig, falsch. Unter eins. Das hängt definitiv mit dem Klientel zusammen. Also die Kinder und Jugendlichen, die die Kinder- und Jugendeinrichtungen besuchen und vor allem als Stammbesucher wirklich jeden Tag oder mindestens jeden zweiten dort eintrudeln, gehören zu den, wie das anderswo genannt wird, eher bildungsferneren Schichten. Das heißt, wir haben einen ganz großen Quotient von Schulverweigern, Schulabbrechern, Schulschwänzern dabei, die in dem Maß, in dem sie sich frei äußern innerhalb der Einrichtung gegenüber ihren Freunden, die auch da sind, sehr gerne davon erzählen, dass ihnen die Schule nicht viel bedeutet, dass sie da gar nicht groß hingehen. Und es ist für uns umgekehrt immer ein Glücksfall, wenn die Schullaufbahn erstens durchgezogen wird und zweitens vielleicht auch noch versucht wird, auf eine weiterführende Schule zu kommen überhaupt, weil die Idee da ist, dass es ja hilfreich wäre und dass man ja auch doch eine Idee hat, wie man mit seiner Zukunft umgeht. Diese Kinder und Jugendlichen interessiert auch dann nicht, wie das Gerät funktioniert. Das soll funktionieren, wenn es davor sitzt und fertig. Wie das auch mit Handys der Fall ist, die dann auch gerne mal durch die Gegend fliegen, wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert oder der falsche Knopf gedrückt wurde oder was auch immer.
Dann wird einfach geschmissen.
Ja, also das ist dann halt eben einfach so. Froh war ich in dem Moment immer, wenn ich Projekte in Kooperation mit Schulen gemacht habe, die Oberstufen betroffen haben, weil das waren dann eher auch diese älteren, elfte, zwölfte, dreizehnte Klasse an Jugendlichen, die also auch in der Realschule neunte Klasse doch eher schon so ein Interesse an ihrer Umwelt hatten und nicht nur ich möchte was machen und das soll sofort funktionieren, weil ich bin der Herr der Maschine. Das waren sie natürlich nie, aber sie fühlen sich so, wenn sie den Knopf drücken und es funktioniert. Warum es funktioniert, hat sie dann nicht interessiert. Die Älteren haben dann eher schon vor allem in Projekt-Workshops wie Machinima zum Beispiel geguckt, okay, wenn ich das herstellen will mit diesem Spiel, dann muss es auch funktionieren, okay, welche Grafikkarte, das ist wichtig und wie das mit dem Spiel ist, was hat der Prozessor für eine Geschwindigkeit, was kann ich erwarten. Da bin ich dann immer sehr froh gewesen, dass es auch diese Querfragen gab, bzw. das Interesse, wie kriege ich das mit dieser Hardware, die jetzt hier drin steckt, überhaupt hin. Das ist aber wie gesagt der Bruchteil gewesen und ich denke mal, das hängt auch wirklich eher mit den Bildungsgängen zusammen. Es gab wenig Kinder und Jugendliche, die sich überhaupt für ihre, also für die Weiterführung ihrer Hobbys interessiert haben. Zum Beispiel im grafischen Bereich gab es sehr talentierte Jugendliche, wo ich immer gesagt habe, Mensch, so ein Blog oder so eine Internetseite für 20 Cent im Monat ist schnell aufgesetzt, dann kannst du deine Sachen veröffentlichen. Warum denn nicht? Das kriegt doch sonst keiner mit. Ja, gut, will ich nicht, kann ich nicht, lass ich mal sein. Aber es gab wenigstens welche, die an ihrer eigenen Zukunft interessiert sind und aber viele sind das halt eben nicht. Ich weiß nicht, in welcher Hinsicht ihre Zukunft irgendwie gestaltet werden soll, aber so auf dem relativ normalen, sag ich mal in Anführungszeichen, schulischen oder ausbildnerischen Weg ist es nicht angesiedelt, nicht unbedingt.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen frustrierend?
Deshalb ist die Fluktuation in diesen Einrichtungen relativ hoch, weil das hält man nur eine begrenzte Zahl von Jahren aus, würde ich mal sagen. Also man wechselt dann vielleicht in eine andere Einrichtung und was Erzieherinnen und Sozialpädagoginnen mitgegeben ist, glaube ich, das muss man auch haben, damit man das längere Zeit machen kann, ist immer so ein Maß an Optimismus, es wird doch wohl irgendwo noch ein Potential von Kindern und Jugendlichen geben, die was mit sich anfangen wollen, damit ich die fördern kann. Wenn man Kinder und Jugendliche hat, die man nicht fördern kann, weil sie überhaupt kein Bock drauf haben, dann sitzt man da mit seiner Förderwilligkeit und seinem Optimismus relativ blöd auf dem Stuhl. Und die, die sich in dieser Richtung äußern, ob das jetzt technisch ist oder ob das von der Ausbildung her ist oder von der weiteren beruflichen Perspektive her, auf die stürzt man sich dann auch so ein bisschen und sagt, Mensch, toll, mit denen kann ich arbeiten.
Und wie geht man dann damit so um?
Na ja, unterschiedlich. Man wechselt Einrichtungen und hofft. Oder man sagt, gut, ich ziehe mich jetzt ein bisschen raus zurück und versuche auf dem Amt, auf dem Jugendamt, Sozialpädagoge kannst du auch da unterkommen, da einen Job zu finden. Dann bin ich einfach so ein bisschen da raus und gebe die Verantwortung, also auch des erzieherischen Auftrags, dann doch wieder eher an die Leute zurück, die ihn originär haben. Weil der erzieherische Auftrag, der ist in den Einrichtungen schon vorhanden. Und ansonsten, naja gut, es gibt viele, die dann völlig was anderes machen und in irgendeiner Art und Weise Supervision oder Coaching beanspruchen, um damit klarzukommen, weil die Realität halt doch anders aussieht als das, was in Ausbildung und auch in der Sozialpädagogenausbildung vermittelt wurde. Weil manche wollen einfach da nicht weiter und dann ist das so.
Aber die, die ja eigentlich den Auftrag haben, da zur Erziehung, sind ja die Eltern.
Ja, natürlich. Und genau, die ziehen sich aber ganz oft da raus. Und dann ist natürlich, da sehe ich dann auch einen riesen Nachfrageaspekt, es ist super, dass es solche Einrichtungen gibt, die nachmittags geöffnet haben, wo sich Leute auch um die Kinder kümmern, die da reinkommen, weil die wollen teilweise natürlich nicht auf der Straße rumlungern und rumlaufen und wollen sich nicht unbedingt Klicken anschließen, was sie aber müssen, weil wenn sie alleine sind, haben sie immer eine Klicke gegenüber. Und es geht immer um einen Bereich, der fußläufig, meines Weges zwei Kilometer Umfang vom Wohnort entfernt betrifft. Die gehen dann in die Kinder- und Jugendanrichtung, weil sie wissen, dort werden sie nicht gemobbt, dort werden sie nicht belästigt und wenn, dann sind aber auch Leute da, die sich darum kümmern. Und es gibt auch noch Angebote, wie jetzt im Medienbereich, Computerraum, da was zu lernen oder auch nur Jonglage zu machen, nur Comics zu zeichnen, Graffiti zu sprühen. Also wo auch noch in den Bereichen, die einem interessieren, was geboten wird. Die wollen nicht unbedingt auf die Straße. Und manche vielleicht schon, aber das sind, glaube ich, wirklich die wenigsten. Und diese Lücke müssen Kinder- und Jugendanrichtungen füllen und diese wird also jetzt auf einer politischen Ebene gesprochen immer mehr zurechtgeschnitten, weil die Einrichtungen von kommunaler Verwaltung jetzt gerade in den letzten Jahren in Charlottenburg-Wilmersdorf, was ich ja eher kenne als Bezirk, an freie Träger abgegeben wurden und da werden dann einfach die Löhne der Mitarbeitenden beschnitten und die haben dann auch nicht mehr so die Motivation und die Einrichtungen werden teilweise geschlossen. Also gibt es diese Angebote einfach in größerem Maße in der Zukunft nicht. Dann landen die Kinder auf der Straße und dann können sie auch nicht mehr mit Computern und Medien arbeiten, weil da gibt es keine.
Und auch nicht mit anderen Sachen.
Ja, also diese Angebote fallen einfach weg und das ist verheerend. Also für die weitere Entwicklung, denke ich mal, können jetzt schon Budgets für neue Jugendknäste angelegt werden, weil irgendwann werden die auch voll.
Also mit anderen Worten, dadurch, dass man sich solche Einrichtungen spart, gewinnt man letzten Endes auch nichts finanziell?
Nein, kurzfristig ja und das ist vielleicht der Effekt, der erzielt werden soll, aber langfristig überhaupt nicht. Weil Bildungsinitiativen, wie auch jetzt von Herrn Zöhner nochmal für dieses Jahr ausgerufen, das Jahr der Medienkompetenzen, wo soll das fußen, wenn Schulen immer noch größtenteils keine Computerräume haben oder welche haben sie nicht betreut werden oder die betreut werden von Lehrern, die sich Überstunden ans Bein binden ohne Ende? Also nicht unbedingt fachgerecht und professionell geführt werden. Das funktioniert als Modell einfach nicht. Also man kann nicht unten abschneiden und hoffen, oben wächst der Baum weiter.
Vielleicht noch mal kurz zu den Eltern und vielleicht auch noch mal so ein bisschen den Fokus mehr auf die konkrete Medienarbeit, die uns ja hier vor allem interessiert. Ich meine, wir könnten jetzt hier viel über Erziehung insgesamt reden und das, was du beschrieben hast, ist ja auch ein generelles Problem dieser Gesellschaft an sich, auch unabhängig jetzt von Technik, Medien etc. Das wissen wir aber auch, oder ich weiß das zumindest so aus meinem Leben, gerade die Sache mit den Computern und dem Internet, das ist ja eine extrem vielfältige Kutzt. Also man kann Dinge lernen, was weiß ich, man kann Tischler lernen, dann kann man super mit Holz umgehen. Damit kann man auch viel tun. Also diese Universalität des Computers, die hat natürlich noch mal so einen extra Geschmack, weil ich hatte immer so den Eindruck, ich kann eigentlich in jede Branche gehen oder ich kann mich eigentlich überall betätigen, weil natürlich das Wissen um Computer und Netzwerke dann später auch einfach so universell anwendbar ist, dass man eigentlich überall Freunde findet sozusagen mit diesem Wissen. Das macht es natürlich so jetzt in meiner eingeschränkten Sicht auch zu einem extrem wertvollen Grundwissen. Es schmerzt dann immer so ein bisschen, wenn dann so ein Desinteresse auf einen zukommt und sagt, ach nee, Computer ist mir zu kompliziert, wenn man eigentlich weiß, dass es jetzt zwar Komplexität hat, aber nicht im einigen Sinne so kompliziert ist, dass man sich dem nicht nähern könnte. Wenn man jetzt nochmal das jetzt sozusagen zu den Eltern zurückschiebt, und ich denke, hier wird auch sicherlich der eine oder andere zuhören und die oder eine andere, die jetzt auch Kinder haben, vielleicht noch ganz jung, habe ich ja auch. Was denkst du, wie kann man dieses Interesse stimulieren oder aufnehmen? Werden da Signale verpasst? Ist das irgendwie eher ein Versäumnis oder sinnet man, muss man mehr Anreize streuen? Lässt sich das letzten Endes gar nicht steuern? Man muss nur reagieren, auf was auch immer kommt. Was sind da so deine Erfahrungen?
Ich habe eine Zusatzausbildung als alter Medientrainer. Das sind viele Fragen aus Kitas oder aus Schulen, die mich bei Elternabenden gerichtet werden. Ich denke mal, es gibt sowieso kein Rezept dafür. Aber Signale werden nicht verpasst, sondern Kinder interessieren sich für das, was in ihrer Umwelt passiert. Und das, was in ihrer Umwelt passiert, sind Bildschirme, sind Smartphones, sind Telefone, sind Radios. Die interessieren sich dafür und wollen auf diese Knöpfe drücken. So schlicht und ergreifend. Da gibt es aber auch jede Menge Material für Kitas zum Beispiel. Oder auch Schulungen über die berlineigene Fortbildungsstätte für Pädagoginnen und Pädagogen, BITS 21, die sich gerade mit Medienbildung in Kitas beschäftigen. Wie kann in Kitas zum Beispiel Medienbildung eingebracht werden? Oder Eltern fragen mich, ist es denn sinnvoll, dass mein Kind vor dem Fernseher sitzt? In welchem Alter? Was soll es denn gucken? Und so. Die Kinder können sich diesen Medien nicht entziehen, wollen das auch nicht. Und diese Signale muss man nicht dahingehend deuten, dass man sowieso nichts tun kann, sondern als Elternteil hat man und sollte man auch immer den Part übernehmen, zu steuern, was mit Kindern in der Umwelt passiert. Das macht man normalerweise sowieso. Ja, und deshalb ist immer meine Rede auch im Medienbereich. Also, man lässt keine Kinder auf die Straße, wenn man ihnen nicht vermittelt hat. Es gibt Autos, die sind gefährlich, und es gibt ein bestimmtes Verhalten, das schützt einen definitiv. In ähnlicher Weise ist es mit dem Fernsehen. Radio kommt kaum noch als Frage auf, oder Zeitung. Also, zeitungssüchtige Kinder habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Podcast-süchtige Kinder sind, glaube ich, die Zukunft.
Das kann passieren. Hörbücher, Extremste, Extrem-Höring. Aber es ist dann eher so die Frage, wann überfordere ich das Kind? Soll ich alles machen lassen? Nein, es sind wie immer Steuerungselemente. Das heißt, es gibt erst mal die beiden Pole-Positions totale Ablehnung. Mein Kind darf bis fünf Jahre keinen Fernsehengucken schlussausfertig. Kann man vertreten, wenn man weiß, was man damit tut. Oder auch, nein, ich parke mein Kind mit anderthalb Jahren vor der Glotze, weil dann kann ich in der Küche zwei Stunden prima rumwirbeln. Und das wird ja nicht geschädigt. Es lernt ja eher noch was davon.
Du bist aber jetzt kein Freund von beiden Ansätzen.
Richtig, deshalb sind sie auch wirklich sehr polar. Und der Punkt ist, was lernen die Kinder, wenn sie irgendein Medium benutzen? Und wie lange ist es sinnvoll, ein Kind sich mit einem Medium auseinandersetzen zu lassen? Was ich persönlich immer gut finde, ist das Ausprobieren. Ob das jetzt im Anwendungsprogramm ist, rumklickern, weil die Maschinen gehen auch nicht mal so häufig kaputt, wie das noch zu früheren Zeiten der Fall gewesen ist. Lernen durch wildes Rumklicken oder auch am Fernsehen. Es gibt von der Entwicklungspsychologie her einfach auch Marken, wo man sagt, Kinder können mit 1,5, 2, 3 Jahren mit dem Fernsehen in dieser Art und Weise, die wir projizieren. Und das ist nichts als ein Projekt, das ist nichts anfangen. Weil die das gar nicht verarbeiten können.
Vom Inhaltlichen her?
Vom Inhaltlichen her. Weil das ist zweidimensional, das hat nichts, was man anfassen kann, das schmeckt nicht, das riecht nicht. Da fehlt einfach ganz viel auf den Ebenen, auf denen sie ihre Umwelt erlernen und auch ihr Leben erlernen. Ab drei, vier Jahre geht das dann auch eher in diese anfängliche Metaebene über, dass Geschichten nicht unmittelbar mit dem Kind selber was zu tun haben müssen. Das verstehen sie, diesen Unterschied. Ansonsten ist es permanent sie selbst und das ist der Mittelpunkt der Erde. Deshalb sind die Geschichten im Fernsehen für sie völlig uninteressant, weil sie können nicht verstehen, dass diese Figur irgendwas tut. Ab drei, vier, fünf Jahre schon. Und da kann man dann auch ansetzen und sagen, okay, das sind jetzt dann nicht mehr irgendwie zehn Minuten, sondern vielleicht 20. Und dann ist die Kiste aber auch aus, weil diese 20 Minuten können verarbeitet werden. Insofern der Kontakt zwischen Eltern und Kind da ist. Die Kinder haben Fragen und die Kinder sitzen gerne mit ihren Eltern davor, die Sendung läuft und sie fragen permanent. Das nervt vielleicht. Das ist, weiß ich selber, nervend. Aber was gelernt werden möchte, das muss auch durch Fragen eruiert werden dürfen. Also es muss ein Rückfragen möglich sein. Und dieses Reflektive ist für die Kinder einfach die Basis, um mit dem, was sie erleben, klarzukommen. Das ist dasselbe wie auf dem Spielplatz, dasselbe wie in der Kita, wo immer wieder nachgefragt wird, warum wird denn die Entscheidung so getroffen? Oder warum darf ich das jetzt nicht tun? Und was macht der da vorne auf der Mattscheibe mit diesem großen Hammer? Also diese Lernschritte sind ganz stark an Eltern gebunden. Und da ist es logisch, sind die Eltern aus ihrem eigenen Erziehungsauftrag in der Pflicht, dieses Verhältnis mit ihren Kindern zu wahren und ganz eng aufrechtzuerhalten und sich als Ansprechpartner zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt mal beim einfachen Fernsehbeispiel bleiben, ist es im Wesentlichen das Begleiten. Also es ist wichtiger sozusagen als die Frage Fernsehen ja nein. Aber trotzdem muss man ja jetzt auch nicht den ganzen Tag damit verbringen, das Fernsehprogramm durchzuschauen. Ich meine, da wird man ja selber total bekloppt dabei.
Bloß nicht. Also für Kleinkinder ist das eine Geschichte von der Sendung mit der Maus oder sonst was für 10, 20 Minuten, würde ich sagen. Und das ist aber auch gut, weil das reicht an Reizen. Und es sind irrsinnig viele Reize. Das können wir uns nicht mal unbedingt vorstellen, weil wir da schon blocken bzw. selektieren. Das machen die Kinder nicht. Die nehmen das einfach für bare Münze. So ist das Punkt. Und da sind 10, 20 Minuten völlig ausreichend. Und dann wird den ganzen Tag gefragt. Neu durchgespielt und diskutiert und noch mal gedreht und gewendet und hintenrum noch mal gefragt. Ja, aber wenn die Figur das jetzt so und so gemacht hätte, was wäre denn dann gewesen? Daran merkt man, die setzen sich damit auseinander. Und wenn zu viel reinkommt, nutzt es nicht genauso viel, sondern es nutzt weniger, weil es ist dann nur noch Reizüberflutung. Also es gibt ja durchaus auch kritische Stimmen, denen ich nicht folge, die dann sagen, es gehört kein Bildschirm in dein Kinderzimmer, bevor das Kind 5, 6 Jahre alt ist. Punkt. Hörnforscher, die in diese Richtung arbeiten. Das sehe ich sehr kritisch und ich denke mal auch, es ist für das eigene Lernen des Kindes an Medien...
Kein Bildschirm im Sinne von kein Fernseher oder im Sinne von kein Bildschirm?
Kein Display, null. Kein Fernseher, kein Computer, kein gar nichts. Computer sollten also auch unter fünf Jahren und auch Fernseher nicht im Kinderzimmer stehen, aber die Kinder sollten davon nicht ferngehalten werden in diesen Altersstufen. Ich finde es durchaus sinnvoll, Lernspiele wie zum Beispiel von der Linux-Live-CD-UX-LALA mit 3-, 4-, 5-Jährigen zu spielen. Das sind Spiele, die ähnlich auf dem Boden mit Holzklötzchen gemacht werden. Buchstabenspiele, Zahlenspiele, Zuordnungsspiele nach Größen. Warum denn nicht? Warum sollen denn ein 3-, 4-, 5-jähriges Kind Vorschulspiele, und die sind von der Yux-LALA-Live-CD zum Beispiel auf dieses Alter ausgerechnet und wirklich ausgerichtet, warum sollen die das denn nicht 10 Minuten mal spielen? Also die Kinder lernen in diesem Alter durch Spielen. Das machen sie auf dem Boden, das machen sie in der Kita, das machen sie später in der Vorschule und Schule. Aber die Computer sind so allgegenwärtig. Das heißt immer, das Argument auch von den Erzieherinnen, die ich jetzt gerade im Medienunterricht habe, ja, die sind überall, wir müssen die Kinder irgendwie darauf vorbereiten. Das hat nicht nur diesen negativen Aspekt, wir müssen sie darauf vorbereiten, weil sie sonst nicht klarkommen, sondern es hat auch durchaus den ganz normalen positiven Effekt, die Maschine ist da, damit arbeiten die Eltern, die klicken da immer irgendwie rum, dann passiert da was, so das möchte ich auch. Die Eltern machen auch andere Sachen, die die Kinder interessieren, das ist einfach so. Die orientieren sich an den Eltern oder an Erziehungspersonen. Und in diesem Bereich kann man sie durchaus auch in zeitlich engen Maßstäben, je jünger die Kinder sind, zu kindgerechten Spielen ranlassen, weil sie halt eben über dieses Medium spielen lernen, wie auch in der Kita oder im Kinderzimmer auf dem Boden.
Mhm, also, ich direkt verstehe, man könnte jetzt verschiedene Sichtweisen aufmachen, beziehungsweise du beobachtest verschiedene Sichtweisen mit unterschiedlicher Bewertung, so da gibt es einmal so dieses der Computer als Bedrohung, so aber man muss sich ja irgendwie darauf einlassen, weil wenn man das nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen zur Kenntnis nimmt, dann habe ich später keine Chance mehr in Beruf, Leben, was auch immer, so, ja, dass man es eigentlich irgendwie verdammt und blöd findet, aber dann der Meinung ist, man müsste ja dann doch irgendwie, aber dann bloß nicht zu viel, so auf der anderen Seite das andere Extrem, so dieses naja, mach doch was du willst, so und jetzt ist die Frage, wie sich das dazwischen irgendwie abspielt. Meine Meinung ist ja auch die Frage, ok, warum soll ich sie nicht mit einem Computer spielen lassen, weil der Computer ist eine normale Sache und das Kind soll es sozusagen genauso mit derselben Leichtigkeit oder Selbstverständlichkeit dem begegnen, wenn auch anderen Dingen. So dann kann man jetzt natürlich auch sagen, ok, jetzt gibt es da diese Spiele, dann habe ich jetzt so meine Pflicht getan. Also ich habe den Computer nicht abgelehnt, aber ich habe es zumindest geschafft, da so nochmal so einen Gartenzaun Computerspiel aufzubauen, dass es bloß nicht darüber springt. Jetzt könnte man aber natürlich auch so einen positivistischen Aspekt daraus ziehen und sagen, na ja, das Spiel mit dem Computer hat aber gegenüber dem Spielen ohne Computer auch irgendeine Qualität. Siehst du das so? Gibt es diese Qualität? Ist irgendwas besonders Gutes daran, dass man jetzt mit Computerspielen oder spielerischer Software, sage ich mal, arbeitet? Gibt es da sozusagen auch noch einen besonderen positiven Aspekt dabei?
Also der besondere positive Aspekt bezieht sich eigentlich darauf, dass diese Medienwelt sich immer mehr auf Bildschirme oder auf mobile Geräte verlagert und die das Alltagsleben und auch die Lebensrealität bestimmen. Insofern, naja, es gibt viele Diskussionen, ob es jetzt noch wirklich speziellen positiven Wert gibt. Aber als Alltagsgerät ist es einfach da und als Alltagsgerät kann es auch im Sinne von Unterhaltungs- oder Spielinstrument kindgerecht in diesen Alltagsstufen eingesetzt werden. So, also vielleicht fasse ich deinen Begriff jetzt von positiven Zweckzecken.
Ich versuche mich da jetzt auch nur selber anzutauschen. Aber es ist immer so eine Frage, wie sieht man das? Und ich glaube, auch viele Eltern sind da auch so ein bisschen so selbst so ein bisschen verkloppt. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite findet man selbst vielleicht Computer total toll. Ja, und man weiß, wenn man das erst mal richtig kann und so. Aber dann hat man immer diese Chancen und Risiken-Ding, hat Angst, sich da so ein bisschen zu vergaloppieren und schätzt ja auch, dass man mal ohne Computer-Dinge erlernt hat und hat so ein bisschen Angst davor, dass die Kinder jetzt von vornherein nur noch sozusagen den digitalen Ansatz an die Welt wählen und all die anderen Erfahrungen, die man früher noch zwangsläufig hat machen können, weil es keine Alternative gab. Also als ich zu Computern kam, da war Internet kein Thema, weil es gab keins. Insofern kann ich meine Erfahrungen mit der heutigen gar nicht mehr vergleichen. Und weil du ja auch eingangs schon gesagt hast, deswegen habe ich das auch gefragt, was ist jetzt interessanter, Computer oder Netze? Ja, die Computer spielen schon gar nicht mehr so eine Rolle, sondern es ist so die Kommunikation, die natürlich jetzt alle reizt. Und ich weiß natürlich, was faszinierend ist, weil ich hänge da selber an der Nadel und kann ohne Twitter nicht leben. Von daher hat man, glaube ich, so ein bisschen auch Angst vor dem, was mir da selbst so passiert ist, dass man das dann nicht unbedingt so auf die Kinder loslassen möchte.
Das ist eine sehr spannende Auseinandersetzung. Und ich finde, das ist immer wieder an Artikeln abzulesen, die aus vielen Umkreisen kommen, ob das vom Club kommt oder von Medienpädagogen. Wie greift dieses Medium in unseren Alltag ein?
Also wenn du das Club machst, erzählst du dir das.
Genau. Da gibt es sehr viele Ansätze. Es ist eine spannende Diskussion und vor allem auch noch nicht fertig. Deshalb denke ich, kann ich da jetzt nicht so eine Antwort darauf geben. Aber es gibt aus einer anderen Perspektive immer das Ding, was bestimmt gerade die Lebensumwelt? Und da sind diese Geräte einfach richtig mitten im Magen vertreten. Insofern wachsen die Kinder damit auf und müssen damit auch irgendwie klarkommen. Das betrifft jetzt nicht die berufliche Perspektive, sondern das betrifft einfach, naja, das ist in diesem Sinne Welt. Und mit dieser Welt werden sie konfrontiert und mit dieser Welt wollen sie auch klarkommen. Die interessieren sich. Ich brauche die Kinder nicht, größtenteils überhaupt nicht dafür zu interessieren. Ich müsste nie auch kein Kind, Mensch, guck mal, das ist eine tolle Maschine. Nee, die stehen davor oder wollen was machen, vor allem machen, weil die sind ja wirklich praktisch orientiert und fragen sich, wie tue ich das? Und dann sage ich, okay, kann ich ja sagen. Und insofern das eigene Ausprobieren und kurze Erklärung und eine Begleitung zusammenspielen, entwickelt sich dann auch diese Kompetenz, mit diesem Gerät irgendwie umzugehen. Und irgendwann vielleicht, okay, was ist jetzt Hardware nochmal und wie funktioniert, warum kriege ich überhaupt ein Bild und so weiter, was wir eben hatten, was jetzt eher so ein bisschen in den Randbereich gedrängt wird, weil es nur um die pure Anwenderei geht. Aber dieses Gerät ist einfach überall präsent. Es wird darüber geredet, es steht in fast jedem Haushalt drin. In der Schule geht es darum, es gibt ja auch durchaus in den Grundschulen auch Lehrerinnen und Lehrer, die jetzt aus den jüngeren Generationen kommen und sagen, ok, du recherchierst jetzt einfach mal zu Hause im Internet zu diesem und jenem Thema und morgen übermorgen drei Tage erzählst du mir das. Das ist inzwischen nicht mehr ganz unüblich zum Glück. Das hängt auch wirklich mit den Generationen zusammen, weil die Älteren nicht auf die Idee kommen zu sagen, benutze doch bitte mal das Internet dazu.
Du hast ja eingangs auch so erzählt, ja, hier Sozialpädagogik, man lernt halt was auch über die Phasen, über die Entwicklungsstufen, die so die Kinder machen. Wenn man jetzt mal so dieses Wissen heranzieht und das jetzt part auch mit deinen Erfahrungen, wie Kinder wann auf Medien, Computer, Technologie im Allgemeinen, Internet im Besonderen reagieren. Jetzt sind wir ja eben schon sehr jung eingestiegen, die ganz Kleinen, ganz Kleinen, nicht zu viel Fernsehen, da sind wir uns alle einig, aber auch nicht außen vorhalten, sprich dosiert, begleitet. Wo siehst du denn da den nächsten Umbruch bei welchem Altersbereich? Also wo entsteht auf der einen Seite bei den Kindern ein neues Interesse, eine neue Fähigkeit? Und wie macht sich das konkret fest? Und wie sollte man dem begegnen?
Also die nächsten Altersstufen, in denen auch im Gehirn was anderes passiert, sind halt zwischen sechs, sieben und acht Jahren. Das ist auch nicht unbedingt falsch, in diesem Alter die Schule beginnen zu lassen, weil das ähnlich auch an der Entwicklungspsychologie angelehnt ist, dass es überhaupt verarbeitet werden kann, kognitive Art und Weise. Und also was ich noch mal ergänzen möchte und auch jetzt für das Thema passt, es geht immer um die Parallelität von sozusagen digitalen Freizeitbeschäftigungen und Analogen. Also Bäume klettern ist wunderbar. Eher auch so diese Vorstellung und die Zeit, die du vor einem Rechner verbringst, gab es früher zumindest mal vor ein paar Jahren noch als Erziehungsidee, die verbringst du bitte auch draußen mit deinen Freunden und machst da irgendwas. Also wenn du eine Stunde vor dem Rechner sein willst, dann musst du mindestens eine Stunde oder zwei auch raus. Kann sein, dass sich das in Zukunft vielleicht ein bisschen verlagert, weil die Geräte einfach immer mehr Raum einnehmen und das auch in der Großstadt nicht so unbedingt umsetzbar ist. Das betrifft aber wirklich zu dieser Idee, analoge Erfahrung bzw. ganz normale praktische Lebenserfahrung, Haptik muss sein, definitiv. Es geht nie um den Ausschluss des einen gegenüber dem anderen, sondern immer um die Integration und auch im Alter von 6, 7, 8 kann man das integrieren. Das passiert im Grundschulbereich eher seltener, weil dort auch so der Übergang der Kita-Vorschule in den Lernbereich –was ja auch so eine ganz bestimmte Art von Lernbegriff ist –rüberwächst. Und ansonsten habe ich im Alter von 10, 11 Jahren –das sind die vierten Klassen –eine Kooperation mit einer Grundschule damals geschlossen und dort für alle vierten Klassen im Jahr, immer im Schuljahr, Computerkurse angeboten, weil in der vierten Klasse der Grundschule in Berlin im Rahmenlehrplan Medienkunde steht. Und was dort als Medienkunde steht, was vermittelt werden soll von Grundschullehrerinnen und Lehrern, betrifft größtenteils das, was die Arbeitsgemeinschaft Kompass in Berlin hier sich als Curriculum für einen Computerführerschein für Kinder in diesem Alter ausgedacht hat. Also habe ich mit allen vierten Klassen dieser Grundschule den Kompass gemacht. Das wird auch im Haus immer noch so gemacht.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Computerkurs, der sich ausgedacht wurde, den gibt es in drei Altersstufen, also es gibt den Junior Kompass, der betrifft eher so 5-, 6-Jährige, da geht es um Motorik, um ganz einfache Sachen, das X-Treffen, Fenster schließen können, CD, ROM einlegen können, Computer hoch und runter fahren, Knopf drücken und der größte und der umfassendste ist auch der Netkompass, der betrifft dann so die 7-, 8-Jährigen bis 12-, 13-Jährigen, danach kommt der für Jugendliche und dieser Netkompass umfasst halt Textverarbeitung, Bildverarbeitung und dann Internet, ganz viel und dieser Block ist immer größer geworden. Die haben in den vierten Klassen die Maßgabe, diese Inhalte den Kindern beizubringen. Das steht im Berliner Rahmenplan Sachkunde für die vierten Klassen drin. Also wie schreibe ich den Computer an und aus? Was ist Hardware?
Im Rahmen welchen Unterricht ist es?
Sachkunde ist es. Und deshalb ist es auch möglich, mit den Grundschulen da zusammenzuarbeiten, weil die das eh machen müssen und insofern ist in den Kollegien immer noch nicht so viele Lehrer und Lehrerinnen gibt, die das in der Grundschule selber im Computerraum oder auch, ja, doch natürlich im Computerraum anbieten können. War es eine prima Möglichkeit, als außerschulische Kinder-Jugend-Einrichtung mit einer Grundschule zu kooperieren in dem Maße und eine Projektwoche draus zu machen oder Projekttage, wie auch immer das zu organisieren ist. Die kommen wir dann auch in die Einrichtung oder ich geh in den Computerraum, was selten der Fall war, weil der immer ausgebucht ist. Und wir machen dann in der Projektwoche parallel Unterricht und Computerführerschein. Und diese Arbeitsgemeinschaft Kompass gibt es ja auch seit über zehn Jahren inzwischen und wurde geschaffen, damit nicht jede Kinder in Jugendeinrichtungen, die mit Computern arbeitet, selber so ein Curriculum für einen Computerkurs oder wie auch immer ausarbeiten muss, sondern alle haben praktisch ihr Wissen zusammengetragen und diese Arbeitsgemeinschaft trifft sich in Vollversammlungen, die auch darüber entscheiden, wie das Ganze weiterläuft und Schwerpunkte setzen. Und das ist eine ganz große Bandbreite, die bei Hardware anfängt und bei Internet- und HTML-Seiten aufhört.
Was mich so ein bisschen vor den Kopf stößt, ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber was für meine Wissensrealität so ein bisschen merkwürdig ist, ist so dieses Okay, Computer, ich werde ein Computer herangeführt und dann soll ich mit einem Programm arbeiten. Ein Programm ist natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht schon immer so etwas, was eben schon bestimmte Abläufe einfach festgesetzt hat und sagt, so hat es jetzt zu funktionieren, so bedienst du mich und du musst alle meine Fehler ertragen. Es gibt ja auch in der Computergeschichte einige einflussreiche, große Denker. Alan Kay zum Beispiel so als einer der Pioniere auch im Bereich User Interfaces, der seinerzeit bei Apple gearbeitet hat, aber auch so dieses Dynabook, im Prinzip schon die Tabletts von heutigen Zeiten vorausgesehen hat und dabei auch immer eigentlich das Lernen, immer die Bildung, immer die Kinder auch im Sinn hatte. Also bei ihm ging es da weniger um dieses, wir brauchen jetzt ein Gerät, mit dem wir im Business besser walten können, sondern es hat ihn eigentlich immer mehr das Lernen selbst interessiert, wahrscheinlich auch einfach getrieben und getragen davon, wie diese Hacker, so nenne ich sie, einfach auch selber drauf sind, dass sie selbst gemerkt haben, dass eben dieser Lernimpuls ihnen einfach alles erschlossen hat auf diesem Planeten. Ein so ein Ding ist ja die Programmiersprache Logo, was wir sicherlich schon mal gehört haben, wo man halt so grafisch selbst Instruktionen gibt, die kleine Turtle, die kleine Schildkröte marschiert über den Bildschirm und zieht Linien. Ist sowas in diesem Programm auch drin oder ist das einfach wirklich nur so ein CD-ROM-Laufwerk-auf, CD-ROM-Laufwerk-zu Programm?
Das Nur würde ich jetzt erst mal streichen wollen, weil dieses CD-ROM auf und zu, das betrifft wirklich den Junior-Kompass, das sind die kleineren und da wird auf die Motorik Wert gelegt, so, dass sie auch mal ein Spiel starten können. Mehr Umfang hat das nicht. Das, was ich eben geschildert habe, ist das Net-Kompass, das ist auch für die 8- bis 13-Jährigen, also insofern die 13-Jährigen nicht eh schon wissen, wie man mit Programmen umgeht. Der Sinn wurde auch aus so einem Begriff von Medienkompetenz aus den 80ern, der auch von Barke eher kommt, darin gesehen, den Kindern Wissen zu vermitteln, wie Anwendungen zu benutzen sind, damit sie selber kreativ tätig werden können. Also du merkst schon, es war klar, wir müssen den Kindern erzählen, wie es geht, damit sie selber kreativ tätig sein können. Also das hat ja auch immer noch einen Sinn, es ist ja auch immer noch so, die Programme vermitteln sich nicht selbstständig. Also du kannst niemanden vor ein Programm setzen, das er nicht kennt und erwarten, dass er dann nach, ich weiß nicht, wie viel gesetzter Zeit das Ding beherrscht und selber vielleicht auch Quergedanken darin umsetzen kann. Also das funktioniert mal, also das funktioniert aber nicht unbedingt mit den Kindern, die ich da kennengelernt habe oder auch mit dem Klientel, das in der Kindernjugend Einrichtung war. Also dieser Aspekt, ich muss Kindern was erklären, damit sie selber was machen können, der wurde in den letzten 10, 20 Jahren auch immer mehr verändert in diesem Aspekt, aha die machen schon was. Ich begleite sie darin, ich muss mich selber auch weiterbilden, weil dieser Begriff, den kann ich langsam aber sicher so in die veraltete Mottenkiste packen, aber Ansätze davon bzw. so Grundstimmungen laufen immer noch. Und es wäre für meine Begriffe zu hoch gegriffen, wenn gesagt wird, die bringen sich das alles selber bei. Die JOSEN-DFAS ist so intuitiv, dass alles nachvollzogen werden kann, soweit sind wir noch nicht. Das wäre wirklich zu hoch gegriffen. Leider Gottes sind die Beispiele, die du jetzt sagtest, wie die Programmiersprache Logo, wenn überhaupt ein Curricula von Gymnasien für die neunte Klasse vorgesehen, dieser informationstechnische Grundunterricht, der gemacht werden muss, im Stundenplan fest verankert, umfasst aber dann ganz oft nämlich nicht Logo, also eher kindgerechte Geschichten, die neuen Klassler aber dann auch nicht mehr interessieren. Mit so einer Schildkröte wollen die nichts mehr zu tun haben. Die müssen dann eher mit, wenn es schlecht läuft, beziehungsweise in Anführungszeichen schlecht, Pascal, Turbo Pascal oder sowas klarkommen oder auch mal Python, das ist dann dann schon fortschrittlich, da gibt es dann Lehrer, die auch nur diese Sachen machen und ganz oft das Office-Paket von einer Firma aus Redmond. Ansonsten ist da nicht viel und es geht immer noch darum, Programm vor die Nase, Kind vor den Computer, beides zusammenbringen und hoffen, dass was daraus wird.
Also so läuft es, aber wie hättest du es denn gern?
Also ich kann mir das ganz anders vorstellen. Computer, die man im Klassenraum sowieso online laufen hat und permanent was nachgucken kann beziehungsweise Lernplattformen, die auch vielleicht einfacher sind als dieses komplexe Moodle oder auch Moodle-Abgespeckt. Moodle? Moodle?
Kenn ich nicht.
Was? Das ist eine Lernplattform. Also wo Aufgaben, Tests, Quizzes, Texte M-Doppel-O-D-L-E eingesetzt werden können, die eben ganz viele Schulen einsetzen. Oder was halt eben ganz weit vorne ist, soziale Netzwerke einsetzen, um mit Kindern zu kommunizieren, um ihnen Lernziele zu stecken oder sowas. Es gibt Versuche in die Richtung, das sind ganz seltene, wie zum Beispiel eine Klasse in Österreich, die komplett mit Handys ausgestattet wurde, wo mobiles Lernen ausprobiert wurde. Die konnten die Geräte in der Phase von, ich weiß nicht wie lange es lief, acht Wochen, mit nach Hause nehmen, konnten darüber auch die Aufgaben von Lehrer und Lehrerin bekommen und bearbeiten, haben auch im Unterricht mit den Handys da gesessen. Natürlich parallel, ja, in Anführungszeichen normalen Unterricht gemacht, aber so eine Integration, die stelle ich mir eher vor, dass es wirklich ein Bestandteil ist und böse gesagt vielleicht auch als Werkmittel benutzt wird. Nicht als, so dass es unser Gott, den müssen wir jetzt anbeten, darüber geht es, sondern schlicht und ergreifend als Instrument eingesetzt wird, genauso wie ein Griffel oder, naja, wie es oft noch ist, Stück Kreide oder so was an der Tafel.
Also wenn ich das richtig verstehe, plädierst du jetzt gar nicht für so eine klar geführte Struktur mit, jetzt musst du das und das und das lernen, sondern dass man eigentlich mehr so macht, auf was ihr wollt und ich begleite euch dann dabei, dass man das so macht?
Doch, irgendwo noch geführt. Also macht, was ihr wollt, führt auch oft dazu, dass sie zum Beispiel zu nicht kindgerechten Seiten kommen und sich da gerne mal austoben. Dann hat man ganz schnell die Diskussion über Pornografie am Hals oder hat die Diskussion über Cybermobbing. Insofern es wirklich in Zukunft immer noch geschafft wird, Versuche abzuschmettern, die das Internet in irgendeiner Art und Weise eingrenzen, müssen wir aber auch mit dieser Freiheit, die wir im Netz haben, an Austauschmöglichkeiten gegenüber Kindern und Jugendlichen in irgendeiner Art und Weise klarkommen, dass Grenzen, die normalerweise face to face nicht überschritten werden, auch im Netz nicht unbedingt, permanent überschritten werden oder sie nicht dazu ermutigt werden. Was heißt die Gefahr? Das Potenzial dazu ist definitiv da. Cybermobbing ist nicht unbedingt ein Stichwort, das jetzt schon wieder veraltet ist, leider.
Ich muss sagen, du kannst mal aufpassen, dass wir jetzt nicht zu viele Dinge aufmachen. Ich wollte noch mal so ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, ob wir da jetzt eigentlich schon so zum Abschluss gekommen sind, aber so diese Entwicklungsphasen. Du hast jetzt gesagt, es gibt so eine Frühphase, drei bis fünf, Kita-Zeit, Vorschulzeit. Da ist so das Heranführen, aber in Maßen ist sozusagen das Gebot, kann man so sagen. Vielleicht kannst du auch noch mal was dazu sagen, was du so Kitas an der Stelle dann empfehlen würdest, wenn du da auch Erfahrung hast. Dann beginnt die Schule, kunditive Wahrnehmung ist deutlich gesteigert und dann wird zumindest derzeit eben auch schon aktiver der Computer als solcher herangetragen, das Netz als solches herangetragen und das findest du insofern ja auch okay. Aber es geht ja dann auch weiter. Was sind denn so die nächsten Phasen in der Entwicklung, wo man jetzt sagen kann, da macht sich jetzt noch mal ein Türchen auf oder ist dann so ab 11 dann irgendwie sowieso alles nur noch eine individuelle Geschichte?
Also noch mal mit der Anregung zurück zu drei bis fünf Jahren, zu den Kitas. Es gibt wie gesagt die Fortbildungsstätte BITS 21, die in diesem Bereich Medienbildungskurse für Erzieherinnen und Erzieher anbietet. BITS 21 in einem Ausdruck.
Reden wir jetzt eigentlich nur von Berlin Brandenburg oder ist das so generell?
Also das ist halt so der Bereich, in dem ich unterwegs bin. Vor allem Berlin, aber auch ein bisschen Brandenburg.
Gibt es da jetzt deutschlandweit auch noch irgendwas, was dir da einfallen würde?
Ältere Medientrainer gibt es auch aus Kommenaufam, auch aus Nordrhein-Westfalen, als Berater für Kitas und Schulen im Medienbereich. Ansonsten gibt es auch in anderen Bundesländern Fortbildungseinrichtungen, die in dem Bereich unterwegs sind, Medienbildung in Grundschulen und Kitas. Also Projekte werden zum Beispiel, also da hängt es auch wirklich davon ab, erstens bei den Erzieherinnen setze ich in der Fortbildung, die ich mache, immer voraus, okay, ihr habt die Zeit und ihr habt das Personal. Das heißt, ihr seid jetzt wirklich in der Lage für das Wunschprojekt, das ihr entwerfen möchtet, weil diese Freiheit braucht man zum Entwerfen, in der Lage alles umzusetzen, was ihr könnt. Das trifft überhaupt gar nicht auf die Realität, weil oft heißt es, okay, du hast jetzt einmal in der Woche oder zweimal in der Woche, wenn es gut läuft, zwei Stunden Zeit mit den Kindern, irgendein Medienprojekt zu machen. Und das heißt auch wirklich irgendeins. Das heißt nicht nur Computer, das heißt auch Film oder das heißt Foto. Ganz oft heißt es dann, du musst es ausfallen lassen, weil wir Personalmangel haben oder das Gerät ist jetzt gerade kaputt oder was auch immer. Also diese Idealbedingungen müssen sein, um überhaupt mal aus dem Schuh zu kommen, sonst funktioniert es nämlich nicht. Und das können ganz kleine Sachen sein. Das kann eine halbe Stunde vor einem Lernprogramm sein und das heißt dann immer nicht ein, zwei Kinder, sondern es sitzt eine Traube von fünf, sechs, sieben, acht Kindern davor, was ja auch sinnvoll ist, weil diese soziale Event, der ist es, der interessiert, dass die Kinder das zusammen machen und sich als Cloud sozusagen Anregungen geben, wie man jetzt auf dem Bildschirm irgendwas handeln könnte. Oder Fotos zu schießen und da einen Fotokalender daraus zu machen, meinetwegen Jahreszeiten gebunden oder Themen gebunden, in denen nur Bäume fotografiert werden oder Vögel der Umgebung oder die Parks oder was auch immer. Also diese Integration von, was erleben die Kinder im Aufwachsen an ihrer Umwelt und der Umsetzung in irgendeiner medialen Art und Weise. Das können dann auch kleine Bildgeschichten sein, die in Präsentationsprogrammen hintereinander geschaltet werden und die Folien erzählen die Geschichte bis zu Ende durch auf zehn Folien.
Und was ist der Lerneffekt dabei?
Der Lerneffekt heißt, ich setze mich mit der Umgebung auseinander, ich setze mich mit dem Thema auseinander. Das kann auch das Thema Wald sein, was er wirklich so in traditionellen Ohren, naja, da müssen die halt eben riechen und da müssen die hin und da müssen die irgendwas ausbuddeln oder so heißt. Das kann aber auch dann auf einem Computer umgesetzt werden, innerhalb von Fotostories oder von Postern, die gemacht werden, um dieses Gerät in seinem Gebrauchswert irgendwo anzuwenden, sodass es wirklich nicht nur diese Unterhaltungsbox ist, die man halt nachmittags hat.
Dann, dass man einfach frühzeitig schon versteht, dass es etwas ist, mit dem man Dinge schaffen kann.
Genau, und mir kommt es ganz oft auch auf das an, was du eben sagtest, diesen universellen Charakter. Man kann mit dem Ding halt wahnsinnig viel machen. Es gibt irrsinnig viele Einsatzzwecke. Und Kinder, die jetzt auch in die Einrichtungen damals immer kamen und gesagt haben, ich will spielen, meine ich, boah, ja, okay, spielen ist ein Einsatzzweck. Ob das jetzt offline ist oder im Netz, irgendein Flash-Game. Schade, weil du könntest wahnsinnig viel mehr machen. Wir haben die ganzen Sachen, wir haben Material, wir haben Software, mach was draus. Nö, ich will spielen. Ja gut, dann darf es halt hier eben spielen, ist in Ordnung. Aber gerade dieser Charakter kann auch in Kitas schon oder auch in Grundschulen schon in ganz kleinen Projekten umgesetzt werden. Es geht eher darum, zu sagen, kleine Sachen, nicht so riesen Dinge.
Warum ist das Spielen an der Stelle so viel interessanter? Also, geht es nicht immer um so einen Belohnungsaspekt? Was belohnt das Spiel beim Kind und was belohnt die Bildung? Warum ist das eine mehr als das andere? Ist das eine Frage des Individuums? Ist das sozusagen so eine persönliche Sache, ob einen das mehr interessiert? Oder ist das auch so eine Prägung, sodass man sich an Ablenkung gewöhnt hat oder an Zerstreuung gewöhnt hat? Oder ist das kein Anreiz, Dinge zu bauen, zu schaffen?
Also warum es interessanter ist, lieber ein Spiel zu machen als multimediales oder Internetprojekt zu starten, denke ich mal, liegt einfach daran, dass es eher zur Unterhaltung und zur Entspannung dient. Und ein Spiel, da hast du halt als Kind direkt Belohnungs- und Erfolgseffekte. Die sind halt eben da. Wenn du die Figur, welche auch immer, durch welches Spiel auch immer, durchmanövriert hast und deinen Taler oder deine Punkte eingesammelt hast, das ist halt eben toll.
Ich will jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass das Spiel keinen Lernwert hat, weil das ist ja nun definitiv auch nicht so. Man trainiert ja auch viele Möglichkeiten, die Wahrnehmung, die, was weiß ich, Fahrenmotorik, Reaktionen, Kombinatorik, Strategie, das steckt ja da alles auch mit drin.
Ja, aber in mir hast du da vielleicht auch jemanden, der jetzt nicht unbedingt so gerne die Spiele für die Kinder so empfiehlt. Ich hätte dann eher auch Interesse daran, mit denen was umzusetzen, ein Projekt zu machen oder was, also einen ganz großen Begriff zu arbeiten, was für die ja auch, oder auch für den, doch für mich schon, aber für die ja nicht unbedingt Arbeit heißt, sondern ja, wir machen was. Spielen denke ich mir gut, das ist in Ordnung, das kann man machen. Ich bin selber aus dieser Ecke nicht unbedingt. Von daher halte ich mich bei der Antwort da etwas zurück und sage, naja, die Kinder mögen das, sie können das und es gibt ihnen Erfolgserlebnisse und das können sie dann halt eben auch machen. Das andere ist natürlich anstrengender. Sie kommen, okay, ich war in einem außerschulischen Freizeitbereich tätig. Da ist es mit dem Bildungsbegriff ganz schwierig, weil das heißt, außerschulisch und Freizeit. Das heißt, sie haben überhaupt keine Lust, irgendwas in dieser Richtung von, ich muss oder soll oder könnte was lernen. Ich sage ja auch nicht, du musst jetzt was lernen, sondern sie merken dann irgendwann, oh, ich könnte was lernen, das heißt, ich muss es anders verarbeiten, nee, dann spiele ich lieber. Also insofern, das Projekt einigermaßen mit anderen zusammen spielerischen Charakter hat, worum wir uns immer bemüht haben und sich andere einrichtet, auch immer bemühen, dieses und das auch hinkriegen. Insofern hat es auch Erfolg, aber wenn ein, zwei Kinder nur da sind, kannst du nicht jeden Tag ein neues Projekt machen und dann setzen die sich auch gerne hin und sagen, okay, ich verdattel jetzt meine Zeit. Das ist auch in Ordnung. Und man kann nicht immer nur pädagogische Lernspiele einsetzen. Das funktioniert nicht.
Ich komme da aber so ein bisschen ins Grübeln, weil ich auch, also ich habe zumindest Lernen immer auch als, also zumindest das Lernen, wo es darum ging, dass ich die Sachen lerne, die ich auch lernen wollte, das war für mich das Spiel. Beziehungsweise es hatte für mich auch einen größeren Anreiz als das Computerspiel. Klar, ich meine, ich habe das natürlich auch gemacht wie alle. Man kommt zu diesen Computern, Games, das ist natürlich alles exciting und so weiter. Man will das irgendwie schaffen und der Level sowieso. Aber es hat dann für mich schnell den Reiz verloren und ich habe irgendwie sehr viel mehr, also der Lerneffekt hat mir sehr viel mehr von diesen Belohnungseinheiten gegeben als Level 23. Keine Ahnung, ob das so selten ist und ob man das irgendwie genauer dahin führen kann. Also ob man irgendwas tun kann oder lassen kann, was diesen Aspekt bei den Kindern auch sozusagen, wo der Kopf aufgeht und sie sagen, ja klar, Lernen ist für mich das tollere Spiel oder ist eigentlich das Gleiche?
Also ich würde mal sagen, sowohl in den Grundschulklassen, die vierten, bis auch die kleineren, möchten, wenn du sie fragst, zu zwei Dritteln oder drei Vierteln auf jeden Fall spielen und du gehörst dann eher zu einer Spezies, die auch etwas zwar gerne gesehen ist, aber nicht so häufig auftritt. Muss ich ja leider sagen, der Großteil ist wirklich eher, okay, wir machen jetzt in einem Kurs zum Beispiel Kindersuchmaschinen und ich erkläre gleich, wie das funktioniert und dann können sie das gerne ausprobieren. Kann man das spielen? Das war das Erste. Was wurde gesucht als Suchbegriff? Spiele. Ja, natürlich. Also dann heißt es, okay, bis zu der Maßgabe in diesem Computerkurs wird nicht gespielt. Punkt, machen wir nicht, weil das könnt ihr in eurer Freizeit machen oder auch danach, wenn er zu Ende ist und könnt gerne nachmittags kommen und dann spielen. Aber wenn wir hier spielen, kriegen wir den Kurs nicht durch. Das heißt, ich setze jetzt hier zwei Begriffe konträr, die ich jetzt gerade auch wieder auflösen möchte in diesem Kontrast. Also Lernen funktioniert natürlich auch anders. Es funktioniert nicht nur, indem es weh tut und indem jemand einem was erklärt, und das muss man sich merken und umsetzen, sondern es passiert nebenbei. Es passiert hier und es passiert dort. Lernspiele sind ja auch nicht so wahnsinnig beliebt, sondern es sind einfach wirklich Unterhaltungsspiele, die beliebt sind. Dort wird auch was gelernt. Aber insofern der Lernbegriff dann als Kontrast zum Spiel gesetzt wird, entscheiden sich die Kinder immer für das Spiel oder der Großteil, sag ich mal. Was daneben passiert, ist dann nicht so interessant. Aber was ich dann wiederum gerne kommen möchte, die Integration von Computern oder auch von Medien in Lernprozesse vermittelt anderen das Gefühl, okay, es geht jetzt nur noch um Medien. Und ich sage, nee, es geht nicht um Medien. Es geht darum, dass die Kinder lernen, mit diesen Medien umzugehen und auch lernen, mit dieser Thematik innerhalb der Medien umzugehen, wie Walderkundungen oder Jahreszeiten oder was auch immer. Das ist Lernen. Natürlich ist das Lernen. Das ist nur ein anderer Begriff. Das passiert nicht nur in der Schulbank, wo jemand vorne und frontal unser Recht abhält.
Trotzdem gibt es ja diese große Kategorie von Lernsoftware, Lernprogramme, Lernspiele. Was macht die aus deiner Meinung nach? Also, wo macht es Sinn? Was ist gute Lernsoftware? Was tut die konkret, für kleine, für große? Was macht man da? Ich habe sowas noch nie benutzt. Also, ich kann aus jeder Software, mit der ich arbeite, lernen.
Ja, das ist ja auch ein Lernbegriff, oder den kann ich ja auch nur unterstützen. Lernsoftware, also da muss ich wirklich auch mal diejenigen Programmierer und Entwickler und Designer loben, die sich damit auseinandersetzen, die sind wahnsinnig hinterher von diesem, das ist ein trockenes Lernprogramm und ich muss jetzt mir irgendwas kognitiv aneignen, wegzukommen, sondern halt spielerische Elemente einzusetzen. Aber was spürbar ist und natürlich auch der Sinn ist, es muss irgendwas vermittelt werden. Bei Vokabeltrainings sind eben egal, wie bunt oder wie minimalistisch oder wie sympathisch diese Comic-Figuren auf dem Bildschirm auch immer sind, Vokabeln dran und die muss man lernen. Oder in Mathe-Spielen sind natürlich die am beliebtesten, die Rechenaufgaben haben und man sitzt an einer Laser-Kanone und muss dann die richtigen Lösungen abschießen. Das hat dann noch so diesen Effekt, okay, es ist ein Ballerspiel, aber es ist eins, wo du die richtigen Lösungen als Mathe-Aufgabe abschießen musst. Tuest du das, kriegst du Punkte. Wenn du daneben schießt oder die falsche Lösung anschießt, kriegst du halt eben keine Punkte. Das ist auch noch sehr beliebt. Aber das ist dann so die optimale Verschränkung von Spiel als Unterhaltung und die Übung in Rechenaufgaben. Alles, was unter diesem Level abläuft, ist schwierig. Beziehungsweise nicht unbedingt schwierig, aber die Kinder merken diesen Geruch des Lernens, der damit zusammenhängt. Und obwohl es sehr viel Material gibt, und für Vorschulkinder ist es halt sehr spielbetont, dass Größenzuordnungs-Spiele gemacht werden oder Zahlenspieler sind, die sind süß. Da sitzen die Erwachsenen und Erzieherinnen stundenlang gerne davor und machen das. Die Kinder finden das dann halt irgendwann auch nicht mehr so interessant. Dann wollen sie doch lieber mitkriegen, wie Super Mario da durchläuft und sie noch mehr Taler einsammeln können. Das ist dann halt eben auch interessant.
Also jetzt wo du es so sagst, fällt mir auf, dass ich früher auch eine Lernsoftware benutzt habe. Und zwar heißt das bei uns Text-Adventures. Einfach Abenteuerspiele, wo ich mit Eingabe, also heute gibt es das auch in gleicher Form mit Grafschaus-Gestaltung, was ich so müsste und solche Abenteuerspiele, wo man einfach so eine geführte Geschichte hat, so eine interaktive Geschichte, die sich halt in Schritten immer wieder offenbart und wo man dann immer wieder auf so Rätsel stößt. Beziehungsweise das einfache Beispiel der Text-Adventures aus der frühen Zeit ist so, du stießt in einer Waldlichtung und die Vöglein zwitschern, was willst du tun? Und dann muss ich halt sagen, irgendwie schau dich herum und so weiter, du siehst da einen Fahnenmast und so und dann muss ich halt selber auf die Idee kommen, da hochzuklettern und die Fahne runterzunehmen und dann merke ich, dass da irgendwie eine Botschaft drauf steht und dann habe ich irgendwie meine Landkarte und dann weiß ich, wo ich hingehen muss und dann finde ich den Geheimgang und dann finde ich den Schatz und dann habe ich meine Gegner. Also das ist ja im Prinzip dieses Lernen im Sinne von ich lerne Rätsel zu lösen, ich lerne strategisches Denken da zu entwickeln, Pläne zu machen, verschiedene Ansätze auszuprobieren, dann zum Erfolg zu kommen und habe da aber trotzdem permanent eben diese Belohnung, dass ich bin schon wieder einen Schritt weiter gekommen. Ist sowas schon mal untergekommen, dass man mit so etwas arbeitet?
Also es gibt solche Adventure Games, die verstecken natürlich in den Fahnen irgendwie Aufgaben bzw. Fragestellungen, die dann im weiteren Spielverlauf gelöst werden müssen. Ist sehr beliebt und funktioniert auch, weil es halt eben den Charakter größtenteils auf dieses Spielen liegt und vor allem auf dieses Rollenspielartige oder Adventure Gameartige. Wird in Schulen manchmal noch eingesetzt und findet jetzt aber, das kenne ich jetzt nicht groß, als Verbreitern. Das sind dann eher so die gut gemeinten Elterngeschenke an die Kinder. Guck mal, das ist ganz nett und wenn es installiert wird oder gespielt wird, dann ist es vielleicht doch etwas anderes interessant. Diese Branche ist wirklich etwas im Abseits, obwohl sie eigentlich gar nicht hingehört, weil die wahnsinnig viel Engagement da reinstecken. Aber wenn die Kinder mitkriegen, es geht jetzt um Mathe, Physik, also jetzt hochgestochen oder sonst irgendwelche Sachen, die sie jetzt nicht nur unterhalten, dann wird es schwierig.
Was ist mit solchen Simulationsprogrammen und Strategieprogrammen? So jetzt auch aus diesem Brettspielbereich, wir hatten ja hier auch einen schönen Podcast zum Thema Brettspiele, was weiß ich so, die Siedler von Katarn, wo man eben auch so Welten erschaffen muss, Trading durchführen muss, permanent so eine Simulation aufrechterhalten muss. Gibt ja auch dieses SIMS auch so als jugendlichen Begeisterung. Ich sehe, das ist schon über den Weg gelaufen.
Das sind eher so die Ansätze, die das andersrum aufziehen. Also die Initiativen, die sich mit Serious Games beschäftigen. Also diese Spiele, die auch zu anderen Zwecken dann gebraucht werden, also in andere Kontexte gesteckt werden. Das sind ganz normale Unterhaltungsspiele, wie Sims zum Beispiel, aus denen man prima Machinimas machen kann. Und da ist dann die ganze Bandbreite gegeben, was man damit anstellt. Das heißt, setze ich eine Themenstellung für ein Machinima in Sims, kann ich da auch Unterrichtsfächer reinsetzen, ohne dass es jetzt so praktisch großartig bemerkt wird. Oder Spiele in historischen Umgebungen. Dann kann ich diese Spiele innerhalb des Unterrichts einsetzen und sagen, ok, dieses Spiel ist jetzt ein Rollenspiel und ihr bewegt euch durch, keine Ahnung, Venedig oder sowas. Anhand dieses Spiels kann ich nachvollziehen, wie ist die Architektur? Stimmt das denn? Haben die das jetzt wirklich gut eingesetzt? War die Architektur damals nicht anders? Wie sieht das mit der Kleidung aus? Also jetzt auf diesen Geschichtsunterricht oder Sachunterricht bezogen, kann ich so ein Spiel prima einsetzen. Gut, das machen jetzt nicht viele, aber das ist immer so unsere Anregung. Mensch, nehmt doch die Sachen, die da sind und baut sie in euren Kontext ein. Und das betrifft ganz viele Rollenspiele oder Simulationsspiele.
Na gut, ich meine, wir müssen ja nicht die ganze Zeit an eine Realität verzweifeln, sondern durchaus auch mal so ein bisschen weiter denken, wohin es denn eigentlich gehen sollte oder gehen könnte. Insofern finde ich jetzt diesen Vergleich ganz gut. Aber das heißt, du zerbrichst eigentlich auch so ein bisschen an diesen Begriff Lernsoftware. Software, die jetzt sozusagen nur dafür gemacht ist. Du hast ja hier so ein Beispiel genannt. Vielleicht kannst du es noch mal ein bisschen genauer erklären. Hier diese Linux-CD Yukslala. Also das ist so eine Live-CD. Also reinstecken, davon booten, schon geht es los. Man muss nichts installieren. Was ist da drauf? Was kann man denn dann damit tun?
Also die Yukslala gibt es jetzt in zweiter Auflage seit ein paar Jahren. Wird auch weiterentwickelt und kommt aus Wien von Sozialarbeiterinnen und Sozialarbeiter aus Wien. Andrea Meyer ist da federführend. Da arbeiten auch teilweise Berliner Leute mit, auch von der Grimmelmannschaft. Und richtet sich an Vorschulkinder. Das heißt, es sind Programme drin, ja Lernsoftware ist es irgendwo schon, aber es sind Programme drin, wo ganz viel mit Motorik passiert. Wo zum Beispiel eine Wippe, wo zwei Clowns abwechselnd drauf springen, dahin geschoben werden muss, dass der zweite Clown auch die Wippe erreicht. Oder es sind Zahlenzuordnungsspiele dabei, wo Zahlen zueinander geordnet werden müssen. Sind Größensortierungsspiele dabei, welche Schuhe passen in welche Regalgröße. So ganz einfache Sachen, die die Kinder auf dem Boden in der Kita oder zu Hause auch machen. Ganz normale Holzspiele, die man vielleicht auch noch kennt. Man hat eben ein Holzbrett und verschiedene Formen, die da eingesetzt werden müssen. Dreieckige Formen passen eben auch nicht in runde ausgestanzte Löcher. Das wurde dann auch als Computerspiel übersetzt. Andere Spiele, wo Figuren zusammengesetzt werden können, diese CD umfasst 3, 4, 5 Menüpunkte, wo verschiedene Spielesammlungen dahinter stehen. Und das ist wirklich eher für den Vorschulbereich ausgerichtet und hat auch eine Baby-Funktion, nennt sich so. Weil das Spiel wird aufgerufen und man kann mit der Tastatur nichts mehr anfangen. Das ist dann eher so für die Kinder, die halt auch mal draufhauen wollen. Und das regnet Buchstaben. Also sie lösen was aus. Aber ansonsten kann der Computer nicht verändert werden oder es passiert auch nichts. Und für die Erwachsenen besteht dann immer nur die Schwierigkeit da, wie komme ich aus dem Programm wieder raus? Weil du kannst drücken, was du willst. Du kommst halt nur mit einer ganz bestimmten Kombination wieder raus.
Das habe ich auch schon mal installiert. Das macht einen ein bisschen verrückt, wenn man nicht draufkommt.
Zum Glück eine Live-CD. Das heißt, die kann man dann auch neu booten. Aber es gibt auch in der Gebrauchsanweisung einen Shortcut, um da wieder rauszukommen. Und solche Spielesammlungen gibt es aber auch von IBM, die auch für Notebooks, die an Kitas gespendet wurden, drauf ist. Das sind halt diese Lernsoftwares, die die Kinder so nicht unbedingt merken. Das tut nicht weh, weil sie halt eben auch das Interesse der Kinder aufgreifen, da die richtigen Sachen zuzuordnen. Oder Schildkröten müssen über den Fluss in ganz bestimmte Höhlen hinein. Und die Enten müssen in andere Höhlen hinein. Das trifft halt eben auch das kindliche Interesse am Computer. Das sind dieselben Spiele, die sie auch auf dem Boden spielen oder ähnliche.
Und dieses Moodle, was du vorhin erwähnt hast?
Das ist eine Lernplattform, so wie Ilyas. Beides auch aus dem Open-Source-Bereich, die ganz viele Schulen einsetzen, die über das Netz laufen, entweder auf einem eigenen Server installiert oder gehostet. Und dort hat man die Möglichkeit, Kurse einzurichten, ganze Klassen zuzuordnen, den Aufgaben zuzuteilen. Und da, wo es übers Netz läuft, kann man da täglich Tag und Nacht ran.
Also so eine komplette Management-Software sozusagen?
Lernmanagement-Software, genau. Heißt auch so LMS.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch ganz praktisch.
Es ist super praktisch und es ist open source. Das ist noch praktischer und das ist sehr komplex. Elias ist ein bisschen abgespeckter. Aber es wird beides auch von Schulen, Hochschulen, Universitäten eingesetzt. Ja, damit man auch wirklich dann lernt, wann man selber Zeit hat. Das ist ja der große Pluspunkt dabei.
Dieser Begriff der Medienkompetenz, der war ja nur schon ein paar Mal da, der ist auch immer schwer zu greifen. Ich kenne das auch so, im Club da wird man auch immer wieder mal von außen angesprochen. Ich war von verschiedenen Gruppen, mit ihr wisst auch so viel und wollte das nicht mehr teilen. Das ist natürlich etwas schwierig. Viele Leute verstehen auch den CCC in seiner Struktur von außen natürlich nicht so. Das sind alles auch nur Individuen, jeder macht irgendwie, was er will. Im Club kommt man halt so mit seinen Kerninteressen zusammen, aber es ist halt nicht so, dass man so organisiert aufgestellt wäre, wie Greenpeace und dann hat er so seine Mission. Dementsprechend sind solche Anfragen selten zu bedienen. Allerdings war Holland so der Gründer, dem lag ja schon immer sehr viel auch an diesem Bereich. Und ich frag mich, was Gruppen, die jetzt mehr Kenntnisse haben, aber die jetzt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne in so einem Lernumfeld angesiedelt sind und dann jetzt nicht unbedingt so, was die beitragen könnten, um einfach diese gesamte Landschaft zu unterstützen. Wo kann man sich einklinken?
Das finde ich auch eine schwierige Frage. Also was in den letzten Jahren, das hängt jetzt mit Kindern und Jugendlichen eher weniger zusammen, interessant gewesen ist, sind natürlich auch die Stellungnahmen des TCC gegenüber netzpolitischen Themen. Da finde ich im Kinder- und Jugendbereich wenig Entsprechungen dafür. Das interessiert mich als Medienpädagogen eher. Also wohin geht es, welche Gesetzesinitiativen oder auch Vorstöße in Richtung Zensur gibt es? Was könnte davon meine Arbeit mit Kindern und Jugendlichen beeinflussen oder auch beeinträchtigen?
Ich wollte jetzt noch nicht so auf diese politische, komm mal, ich lege es gleich mal drauf, aber das war jetzt nicht so das, was ich meinte, sondern so dieses, es gibt ja so dieses Problem, es gibt immer von einem zu wenig. Du hast gesagt, Schulen haben eigentlich, müssen eigentlich, Grundschulen müssen eigentlich irgendwas anbieten. Die haben ihren Lernplan, müssen irgendwie Dinge vermitteln. Gibt es denn da Punkte, wo man sich jetzt auch engagieren kann, wo man irgendwie einsteigen kann, wo geradezu Schulen Händeringen danach suchen? Das weiß ich, dass man als, dass man irgendwie Kurse macht oder Vorträge hält oder keine Ahnung, Demonstrationen macht, dass man auch etwas von außen hereinträgt, einfach auch, um so ein bisschen vielleicht den, ja, das Feuer überhaupt erstmal so ein bisschen lodern zu lassen. Es ist sicherlich etwas schwierig, immer so dieses Schüler-Lehrer-Sprich-Sprich-Erzieher-Verhältnis und dann ach, jetzt wollen sie mir wieder irgendwas reindrücken. So, aber wenn dann so, glaube ich, so eine dritte Person dazukommt, dann sieht das ja wahrscheinlich ganz anders aus.
Das ist der Vorteil der dritten Person, die von außen kommen. Die Form ist ganz oft Projektarbeit, das heißt Projektwochen, Projekttage. Aber das Ganze ist eine zweischneidige Sache. Es gibt sehr viel Fach- und Sachkompetenz außerhalb von Schulen und viel zu wenig innerhalb von Schulen oder Kitas. Nur, diese Personen sollen ja auch nicht unbedingt umsonst arbeiten. Das betrifft einen Tag, zwei Tage, eine ganze Woche. Die Finanzierung ist schwierig. Also, ich habe in dem Bezirk Charlottenburg-Wilmersdorf auch an Schulen jahrelang rumgebohrt. Bis es mal eine Öffnung gegenüber dem Thema gab. Und bis es über die, ja, meistens Personalkostenbudgetierung als Vertretungsmittel bewerkstelligte Finanzierung gab. Also bis wirklich die Notwendigkeit zu, ich weiß nicht, einem Leiden geworden ist, wir müssen das jetzt haben, wir müssen das, okay, dann müssen wir es aber auch bezahlen. Weil du könntest Arbeit an Schulen machen ohne Ende, wenn du sagst, ich mach die unbezahlt. Also da würde jede Schule dich sofort einverleiben und festketten. Daran mangels gar nicht, überhaupt nicht. Da kann man sich auch wirklich die ganze Bandbreite überlegen an Internet-basierten oder Offline-Projekten, da ist alles drin. Weil es auch viel zu wenig Lehrer und Lehrerinnen gibt, die sich damit auskennen und sich auch diese Mehrarbeit, die es immer noch ist, ans Bein binden. Das hängt größtenteils an einer Finanzierung, die nicht da ist.
Aber es gibt jetzt auch keine Organisation, die jetzt solche Pools anbietet, wo man sich melden kann, wenn man jetzt wirklich Lust hat. Klar, jeder kann zu der nächsten besten Schule laufen, aber es muss ja auch irgendwie passen.
Nee, gibt es in dem Sinne noch nicht. Das wäre jetzt auch praktisch so ein Wink mit dem Zauernfall, einen Senat solche Koordinationsstellen zu schaffen, die sich darum kümmern, Fachleute an Schulen zu vermitteln. Weil beide Seiten haben Bedarf. Die Senatsverwaltung ist ja nicht taub gegenüber Förderung von Medienkompetenz oder Medienbildung. Und die Schulen überhaupt auch nicht. Aber die kommen nicht so richtig zusammen, was das Feld eher für Vereine, kleine Firmen oder so was bereitet, die halt sagen, okay, das ist unser Betätigungsfeld, wir verdienen damit Geld, wir versuchen das Kollegium und vor allem den Direktor, die Direktorin zu überzeugen und lassen uns dafür bezahlen. So, davon erfährt man aber auch nichts. Da ist nicht viel Austausch. Das halten die aus privatwirtschaftlichen Gründen natürlich auch unter der Decke, die ist ja auch in Ordnung. Da passiert Bildung. Aber das passiert nicht in dem Sinne, wie du das eben formuliert hast. Es ist transparent, man weiß, was nachgefragt wird und man weiß als Fachmensch, Mensch, da kann ich auch mal hin, da kann ich eine Veranstaltung zu machen, weil das weiß ich. Gibt es leider Gottes nicht.
Jetzt hast du es ja schon angesprochen, so diese ganzen netzpolitischen Bewegungen bzw. auch die grundsätzlichen Fragen. Wie geht man jetzt so in der Politik mit dem Thema Jugendliche und Netze um? Das ist ja auch ein sehr, sehr weites Feld. Diese ganze Zensursala-Debatte hat das ja auch auf eine sehr unangenehme Art und Weise klargemacht, dass das Netz auch primär immer noch als Bedrohung angesehen wird.
Wie siehst du das? Ich kann mir immer nur verdeutlichen, wie die Jugendlichen das Netz ansehen. Das ist für sie eine riesen Spielwiese. Und ich hatte eben schon gesagt, es geht im Moment auch mit dem Web 2.0 und den sozialen Netzwerken eher um Begleitung als darum, ihnen was beizubringen. Das ist der Ansatzpunkt, der in Schulen oder auch in außer-schulischen Einrichtungen gefahren werden sollte. Und nicht von außen versucht werden sollte, Öffnungszeiten im Internet einzurichten oder Netzsperren, in denen sie nichts nutzen, als die Inhalte nicht doch gelöscht werden. Die Jugendlichen sind da unterwegs und es geht darum, dieses Bewusstsein zu fördern. Das Ding ist öffentlich. Da kann ich erzählen, was ich will, aber es wird auch immer noch Jahre später recherchierbar sein. Und soziale Netzwerke sind toll. Deshalb heißt es ja auch, Mensch, ihr Jugendeinrichtung geht da rein, macht euer Profil. Aber es sollten nicht diese Einschränkungsversuche von außen sein, weil die nutzen in den Einrichtungen selber auch nichts. Wenn die Jugendlichen mitkriegen, sie landen auf gesperrten Seiten, versuchen sie da, diese Sperren zu umgehen. Das ist furchtbar einfach.
Wie verbreitet sind das Sperren und Filter in Schulen und ähnlichen Einrichtungen?
Das wird von Schulen und Einrichtungen unterschiedlich gehandhabt. Wir hatten zum Beispiel immer einen pädagogischen Filter. Das heißt, wir haben auch eine räumliche Anordnung, wo wir mitkriegen, was die Jugendlichen machen. Einfach so, wie die Geräte stehen. Wir hatten einen Einblick ohne Software auf die Bildschirme. Das ist einfach so soziale Kontrolle. Wir rufen Jugendliche auf Porno-Seiten auf oder Handy-Klap-Filme, die Prügelszenen zeigen. Dann haben sie aber von uns einfach ganz schnell ein Gespräch an der Backe. Da entscheidet sich dann auch, das sind die Regeln, die hatten wir auch mal verschriftlicht. Obwohl immer weniger gelesen wird, hingen dann Plakate. Keine pornografischen, rassistischen, narzisstischen Seiten. Keine Beleidigung, kein Cybermobbing usw. Insofern, so was dann nicht befolgt wird, ist es dann erste Ebene Gespräch, zweite Ebene, mal gucken, wie er oder sie sich im Gespräch verhält. Einsichtig oder auch nicht, oder weiß das eigentlich, will aber einfach mal gucken und geht dann auch wieder raus. Ja, oder auch bis zu einem, okay, das war's dann für heute, wir sehen uns morgen wieder, weil das hat jetzt nicht das gebracht. Wenn du immer noch der Meinung bist, du musst unbedingt auf irgendeine XXX-Seite, dann kommen wir hier nicht zusammen. Andere Einrichtungen haben, Wächterkarten zum Beispiel, oder haben...
Wächterkarten?
Wächterkarten, also die, die das Betriebssystem wieder auf null zurücksetzen, wenn das Ding abgemeldet wird, weil auch gerne mal Desktops verändert werden oder Sachen runtergeladen werden.
So was meinst du, so wieder entstehende Systeme.
Genau, also die das System definitiv auf lange Sicht kaputt machen, wo man dann irrsinnig viel Arbeit hat, das wieder hinzukriegen. Oder setzen Internet-Cafés-Software ein, um die Bildschirme für eine bestimmte Zeitintervalle überhaupt freizugeben. Mit oder ohne Bezahlung, wie die Einrichtung das intern regelt. Es gibt auch welche, die machen Internet-Benutzung völlig kostenlos. Andere verlangen kleinen, also wirklich kleinen, symbolischen, eher obolos dafür. Und benutzen solche Software, die das regelt. Halbe Stunde, Stunde freischalten und danach fällt der Vorhang. Andere regeln das nur über Listen. Also, man trägt sich eine Liste ein, hat eine halbe Stunde. Und die Person, die den Computerraum betreut, muss dann auch gucken, wann die halbe Stunde vorbei ist, weil die vergessen das regelmäßig. Und sind der Meinung, nach drei Stunden, die waren nur fünf Minuten im Netz. Das ist halt so der Zeitfresser. Das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Schulen setzen manchmal die richtige Technologie ein, indem sie Linux-Server benutzen. Ganz viele wenden sich aber auch an Microsoft und haben dort die Schulsoftware bezogen und haben dann die entsprechenden Kosten am Hals, kriegen auch den Support oder kriegen ihn vielleicht doch nicht und wurschteln sich durch. Also ganz viele arbeiten mit eigenen Stilen. Und es ist super unterschiedlich, was da als Schutz jetzt eingesetzt wird. Die meisten, denke ich, sind aber technisch unterwegs und die wenigsten mit pädagogischen oder sozialen Filtern oder halt sozialer Kontrolle oder halt wirklich hingucken. Man will den Jugendlichen ja auch vertrauen. Man richtet Zockerräume ein, wo halt wirklich auch Spiele gespielt werden. Und dann vertraut man ja auch darauf, okay, das beaufsichtigen auch Jugendliche und zwar in der Woche immer eine Reihe um. Ihr beaufsichtigt euch praktisch selber. Und der eine oder die eine ist dann verantwortlich. Man kann da nicht garantieren, dass sie das Spiel beenden und woanders hin mal eben kurz gehen. Kann man nicht. Weil das Netzwerk gebunden ist, kann man auch nicht das Netzwerk kappen. Das ist eine Vertrauenssache und es geht auch mal schief. Man kann hundertprozentig da nicht irgendwas einrichten. Das funktioniert nicht. Man kann es nur so weit machen, wie es irgendwie geht. Und wir wissen ja, dass es genug Möglichkeiten im Netz gibt, irgendwelche Umwege einzuschlagen, um doch dahin zu kommen, wo man hin möchte. Das wissen die auch.
Diese Diskussion um den Jugendmediendienst-Staatsvertrag, die jetzt zum letzten Jahr gelaufen ist, die ja dann so ein bisschen, kann man fast sagen, eigentlich von der deutschen Blokosphäre solange traktiert wurde, bis es sich dann politisch nicht mehr durchsetzen ließ, zumindest meine Wahrnehmung. Wie hast du das wahrgenommen?
Also auch in dieser Art und Weise, weil ich auch mit den Leuten so ein bisschen auch von JugendOnline zum Beispiel unterwegs bin, die sich um Jugendarbeiten, sozialen Netzwerken kümmern und natürlich auch um Versuche, Internetsperren einzurichten oder solche Verträge, um Öffnungszeiten im Netz einzuhalten, die das durchaus auf allen möglichen Ebenen immer wieder zum Thema gemacht haben und gesagt haben, das funktioniert so nicht. Also das ist auch, glaube ich, die einzige Ebene, die auch durch Einrichtungen, wie die das Bundesministerium da geschaffen hat, so eine große Öffentlichkeit überhaupt schaffen können, dass das gehört wird. Lass diese Versuche sein. Wenn diese Widerstände nur aus Kindern, Jugendeinrichtungen, aus Schulen oder von einzelnen Medienpädagogen gekommen wären, würde ich mal sagen, hätte das so nicht funktioniert, dann wäre dieser Staatsvertrag durch und wir hätten diese komischen Regelungen.
Aber der Widerstand war sozusagen auf breiter Front?
Habe ich so erlebt. Das kann natürlich an meinem Tunnelblick liegen, dass ich auch über Netzwerke oder auch Micro-Blogging-Dienste auch mit denen nur vernetzt bin, die in diesem Bereich arbeiten und sich umtun. Da passiert es aber verdammt oft. Und das hat irgendwo dann doch eine Auswirkung gehabt, sage ich mal.
Was sind deine Kritikpunkte daran gewesen?
Na ja, das ist einfach Versuche waren, die Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten zu beschränken, die man hat und die den eigentlichen Reiz auch ausmachen. Man kann keine Öffnungszeiten einführen, man kann keine Altersbeschränkungen für Seiten einführen. Das sind nicht handhabbare oder auch für viele Blogbetreiber zum Beispiel nicht umsetzbare Richtlinien, die gerade die Kreativität, die das Netz geschaffen hat und auch weiterhin fördert, beschneiden würde, was im Endeffekt nach hinten losgeht. Ich hatte auch nicht unbedingt das Gefühl, dass diejenigen, die das betreiben und die das gerne möchten, egal aus welchen Motiven, so durchblicken, dass sie merken, sie sägen sich aber auch den Ast, aber sie selber sitzen. Weil sie könnten natürlich auch das Netz nutzen, insofern Social Media zum Beispiel intelligent eingesetzt wird für Unternehmen oder Parteien. Diese Ansätze gibt es ja. Gleichzeitig kann man aber nicht unbedingt sagen, wir wollen das jetzt nur zuschneiden auf legale und tolle Inhalte und so eine heile Welt aufbauen. Das klappt eben einfach nicht.
Aber welchen Bedarf an Jugendschutz siehst du denn? Gibt es überhaupt einen?
Also Bedarf sehe ich schon. Und das betrifft dann auch die Veranstaltung, die ich als Elterntrainer mache oder die Kollegen und Kolleginnen in Elternabenden von Kitas und Schulen machen. Dass ein Bewusstsein darüber geschaffen wird, was machen die Jugendlichen in den Netzwerken? Was machen die im Netz? Was suchen die auf? Was produzieren die? Und das ist leider Gottes der kleine Teil, der auch was produziert, der größere Teil konsumiert und vor allem kommuniziert. Mit welchem Bewusstsein wird das gemacht? Und wo kann ich ihnen auch beistehen als Einzelperson, als Medienpädagogin oder Medienpädagoge oder auch als Einrichtung, die sie kennen und die sie am nächsten Tag auch ganz zu Fuß aufsuchen können? Das Bewusstsein sollte schon existieren, dass es ein weltumspannendes Netz ist. Und Frau Aigner hat den Satz ja prima auswendig gelernt, das Internet vergisst nichts. Das sagen wir seit Jahren. Das kommt nur dann nicht an die Öffentlichkeit, wenn wir so eine kleine Stimme haben, die wir halt eben nur haben. Aber es muss unbedingt irgendwo, es muss auch in diese Köpfe, das passiert auch, und es hat auch einen Erfolg, dass eben keine riesengroße Spielwiese ist, die völlig unkontrolliert benutzt werden kann, sondern es war eine Zeit lang so die Rede von Gefahren und Möglichkeiten im Netz. Ja, das gibt es alles. Es gibt Blogs, es gibt Netzwerke, tobt euch aus, macht alles, was ihr wollt. Dann so, obs, ja, es gibt aber auch Gefahren und Risiken. Es gibt Pädophilie im Netz, das ist einfach so. Es gibt Pornografien, es gibt Gewaltverherrlichungen, es gibt Nazis im Netz. Dann kann man nicht immer sagen, tobt euch aus. Das ist ein bisschen zu heikel. Dann war der Schwerpunkt auf den Gefahren und Risiken. Dann hieß es nur noch, okay, wir richten Verbote ein, das wollen wir alles nicht haben, dieses böse Zeug. Das funktioniert aber auch nicht. Inzwischen sind wir eher dabei, zu sagen, Gefahren und Risiken gut und schön. Das ist real und leider Gottes vorhanden, aber es geht um die Möglichkeiten. Und die Möglichkeiten sollten dieses Bewusstsein um Gefahren und Risiken und das Potenzial vereinen. Dass kommuniziert wird, dass ausgetauscht wird, aber dass die Datensphäre eingehalten wird, dass man seine Intimdaten wirklich nicht permanent rumpostet, nicht irgendwelche Fotos reingestellt werden und es sich nicht so veröffentlicht wird, dass jemand nachvollziehen könnte, der es unbedingt wollte. Diese Person finde ich auch im realen Leben hier und dort. Und das funktioniert zum Glück. Also ganz viele Jugendliche wissen in sozialen Netzwerken zum Beispiel um Privatsphäre einstellen. Das heißt nicht unbedingt, dass sie die auch umsetzen. Aber es ist zumindest mal so weit gesickert, Mensch, da gibt es was, was ich einstellen könnte. SchülerVZ ist zum Beispiel dabei, seit Jahren den Leuten zu erklären, Mensch, stellt diese Sachen so um, dass ihr sie erstmal wirklich ganz eng habt. Euer Profil ist nicht überall sichtbar, euer Profil darf nicht öffentlich aufgerufen usw. Das haben sie per Text gemacht, das haben sie per Video gemacht. Also Text wird nicht gelesen, die Videos werden noch geguckt, das war schon mehr. Inzwischen hat SchülerVZ das bei Neuregistrierungen umgestellt und gesagt, wir schränken die Profile erstmal ein. Die User müssen sie peu à peu selber öffnen. Das ist in der Altersklasse auch definitiv sinnvoll. Das kam aber auch erst nach riesen Protesten, dass unter 12-Jährige ein superoffenes Profil haben. Das heißt, man muss auch was dazu sagen. Andere Portale sind immer noch, Facebook wird das wahrscheinlich nie ändern, permanent und von Anfang an offen wie ein Scheunentor. Mit Anwendungen, was wir alle wissen, mit Zusatzservices. Das ist das Geschäftsmodell, klar. Aber da heißt es auch wirklich, Mensch, Jugendliche, passt auf, was ihr da macht. Das ist dann die Ansprache an die Eltern auf Elternabend. Das ist die Ansprache an Jugendlichen, Einrichtungen und Schulen. Guckt einfach mal hin. Ihr könnt ja wahnsinnig viel machen. Das ist ja der Sinn davon. Aber wisst, was ihr tut. Und verhaltet euch eben entsprechend.
Das sind ja jetzt auch alles im Wesentlichen Empfehlungen. Oder leitest du daraus auch etwas ab, wo man auch durchaus eine gesetzliche Maßnahme sinnvoll sein könnte? Also klingt für mich jetzt mehr so nach, wenn ich ein soziales Netzwerk aufbaue, dann muss ich die minimalste Privatsphäre in Einstellung machen. Aber es ist natürlich auch schwierig, so etwas in ein Gesetz zu kippen, weil das kann dann mit der nächsten Art von Software auch schon wieder so dermaßen an der Realität vorbeigehen, weil einfach die Konzepte ganz andere sind, als die, mit denen wir es jetzt gerade zu tun haben. Also braucht man gar keinen Jugendmedienschutz-Staatsvertrag?
Ich denke mal, den braucht man nicht. Die sind zwar jetzt an einer Novelle und an dem Versuch, das Ganze an die Realität so ein bisschen näher heranzuführen. Ich denke, generell ist es mit Gesetzen schwierig, weil die Versionsstände sozusagen festschreiben, die dann schon längst veraltet sind, wenn das Gesetz durch den Bundestag durch ist. Umgekehrt mit Empfehlungen, wie du sie eben genannt hast, arbeiten wir seit Jahren in Öffentlichkeitsveranstaltungen an Schulen und Kitas und haben eigentlich ganz guten Erfolg damit. Das heißt, wenn man sich mit den Eltern oder auch den Kindern und Jugendlichen auseinandersetzt, kommt das, was man erzählt, auch irgendwann mal an. Das ist nicht sofort der Fall, aber es ist vor allem dann der Fall, wenn die merken, dass was da erzählt wurde von diesen komischen Medienpädagoginnen und Pädagogen, das habe ich auch gelesen, das habe ich im Schulhof gehört, das sagt eine Lehrerin und das kommt auch im Fernsehen. Muss ja wohl irgendwas dran sein. Und die sagen alle dasselbe, so ungefähr zumindest. Das heißt, diese Arbeit, Empfehlungen auszusprechen in dieser und jeder Richtung, hat durchaus auch einen Sinn. Und ich finde sie wesentlich schneller und wesentlich treffender auch für die Leute, mit denen wir umgehen. Und das sickert einfach viel mehr durch, als wenn ich ein Gesetz beschließe, das nach drei Jahren komplett veraltet ist, für den Stand, der dann existiert, und Vorschriften macht, die man einhalten muss, wo man gerne auch mal, gerade im Internet, Vorschriften nicht einhält.
Diese Sache mit diesen Gefahren. Ich meine, das ist immer so schnell gesagt. Na ja, das Netz, das ist ja gefährlich. Ich meine, klar, wenn es jetzt um Betrüger geht, Leute, die jetzt, was weiß ich, diese pädophilen Problematik, dass man da über Chats in Verabredungen hineinlaufen kann, die dann potenziell negative Auswirkungen haben kann, das sind, sagen wir mal, sehr nachvollziehbare, unmittelbare Gefahren. Also konkrete, verbrecherische Bedrohung, sozusagen. Bei der Privatsphäre ist es ja schon so ein bisschen so eine Interpretationssache, inwieweit da jetzt wirklich ein Bedrohungspotenzial dadurch besteht. Aber bei so Sachen wie politische Inhalte, man kann jetzt lange so diskutieren, ob Nazi-Seiten politische Inhalte sind. Oder nicht einfach nur Schund. Aber inwiefern, und auch so Pornografie, was ja auch immer so der Klassiker ist, so ja, XXX ist böse, da frage ich mich immer so, okay, alles klar, das kann man jetzt nicht mögen, aber das steht ja dann doch irgendwo auch in einem ganz anderen Zusammenhang. Wo siehst du jetzt sozusagen die eigentliche Bedrohung durch diese ganzen Aspekte, die du auch selber aufgezählt hast? Und was ist eigentlich so die Realität, wie die Jugendlichen mit dieser Bedrohung umgehen? Also sind die auch wirklich so anfällig? Also wo muss man wirklich jetzt so eine Schutztätigkeit aktiv übernehmen? Wo ist es eigentlich nur eine Frage der Begleitung? Und wo ist es vielleicht auch sinnlos?
Also ich möchte keiner Bewahrpädagogik das Wort reden, die Kinder in eine heile Welt pflanzt und da den Riegel vorschiebt, die Glasklocke drüber stülpt und sagt so, perfekt. Da draußen ist das Böse, hier drin ist gut und fertig. Umgekehrt sehe ich anhand der Praxis von Jugendlichen, die in der Kinder- und Jugendanrichtung waren, seit Jahren, in der ich gearbeitet habe, sehe ich einfach manchmal die Auswirkungen. Ich habe ja eben schon gesagt, wir hatten da keine technische Filter, sondern es waren selber die pädagogischen Filter. Das heißt, sie landen dann auch auf Porno-Seiten und sie landen auch auf Nazi-Seiten und gucken sich das an. Und dann gucke ich mir an, wie reagieren die darauf? Wie gehen die damit um? Was sind die Auswirkungen? Was ich nicht tue, was ich nie getan habe und auch nie machen werde, ist natürlich mal gucken, ist jetzt seit zwei Minuten offensichtlich auf einer Seite, weil das kriegt man mit auf welchen Seiten die sind, durch das Getuschel und Blarr und so. Das darf nicht auffallen, fällt dadurch natürlich immens auf. Ich warte jetzt nicht eine halbe Stunde, wie die Auswirkungen von Porno-Seiten auf Jugendliche sind. Das mache ich einfach nicht. Aber das lässt sich auch anhand von einem Gespräch nach einer Minute oder zwei Minuten schon rauskriegen. Es gibt durchaus auch gerade, was sie gerne gemacht haben, bei YouTube irgendwelche Filme von Handys, die Prügelszenen zeigen. Das sind Sachen, das klingt vielleicht jetzt blöd, aber ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass sie die verarbeiten können, sondern das sind eher Sachen, an denen sie sich anhand ganz komischer Bilder orientieren, für ihr weiteres Aufwachsen. Diese Bilder von Klicken, von Gewalthandlungen heißen einfach nur, okay, es gibt das Paradigma, ich muss brutal sein und da muss ich irgendwie hin. Das heißt, die Kleineren versuchen sich dann auch, und das ist in immer jüngeren Jahren, was ziemlich erschreckend ist, in so eine Gangster-Pose irgendwie reinzukriegen, was in dem Alter von 10, 11, 12 immer ein bisschen hilflos und lächerlich aussieht, aber was ich aufgreife ist dann in dem Moment, da bin ich dann irgendwo auch Sozialpädagoge only, dieses Ding, das ist mein Vorbild, das ist meine Orientierung, da will ich hin. Und das zählt was, damit bin ich top.
Warum? Nur weil das im Netz zu sehen ist? Nur weil die anderen das machen? Es gibt ja auch viele andere Sachen, die im Netz da sind, die können ja genauso gute Vorbildfunktionen haben.
Also in den Kinder- und Jugendeinrichtungen nicht, da gibt es leider Gottes diese Verquickung von den Jugendlichen, die auch außerhalb vom Netz und außerhalb von den Einrichtungen darauf bauen, in Klicken den Starken raushängen zu lassen. Und das ist ihr Lebensmodell und das suchen sie auch im Netz. Und dann frage ich mich, ist es manchmal nicht sinnvoll, wenn diese Inhalte dann nicht auch noch beigefüttert werden? Oder wenn es Pornoseiten sind, das sind Rollenmodelle von Männern und Frauen, die sind einfach nicht dazu geeignet, demokratische Gesellschaften weiterzuentwickeln. Und es ist eher ein Rückschritt. Also diese Männer- und Frauenmodelle gibt es ja nicht nur in der Pornografie, sondern auch in diesen Hip-Hop-Welten. Und wenn dann 12-, 13-, 14-jährige Mädels sich wirklich für die Kinderdisco aufdrucken und in Sachen ankommen, wo ich denke, mein Gott, also wie billig soll es denn noch aussehen? Dann ist das ein Rollenmodell, das ich da nicht mehr gut finde. Und diese Verschränkung von Inhalten aus dem Netz mit einem Verhaltenskodex aus Schulhöfen oder von der Straße, die finde ich fatal. Und das thematisiere ich in dem Moment natürlich auch. Vor allem, wenn es zu Schwierigkeiten kommt, die es dann immer kommt. Gerade auch die Mädchen werden mies behandelt, die Jungs werden von anderen verkloppt. Na ja, das sind dann die Probleme aus diesem Modell. Dann kann ich mich aber mit denen über dieses Modell unterhalten. Da ist dein Ansatzpunkt. Jetzt ganz blöd formuliert der Meinung, dass das, wenn du so auftrittst, auch irgendwas damit zu tun hat, was du als Reaktion bekommst. Also wohin willst du dich denn orientieren? Da frage ich mich dann auch selber, ob die Inhalte im Netz nicht besser zensiert werden sollten, damit es nicht nur wirklich Futter ist in diese Richtung. Zensur ist es aber in dem Moment nicht, finde ich. Weil wenn das eine zensiert wird, geht eine halbe Stunde später auf einem anderen Server irgendwo anders auf der Welt dasselbe noch mal auf. Also funktioniert das Modell nicht, Zensur. Das heißt, diese soziale Geschichte ist in Schulen und Einrichtungen der Kinder- und Jugendarbeit möglich. Und da sollten Medienpädagoginnen und Medienpädagogen auch einreingehen in dieses Feld sozusagen.
Aber es ist eine sehr aufwändige Geschichte. Deswegen versteht man das dann auch schnell so dieser Ruf nach, wenn wir es aber regeln könnten und wenn jetzt jede Porno-Seite ihr Pornosiegel trägt, dass wir sie automatisch herausnehmen können, wenn sie von der Schule aus angeschafft werden, das ist dann sozusagen der Vater des Gedankens. Trotzdem hast du ja gesagt, die ganzen Einrichtungen dagegen gewesen, so eine Regelung herbeizuführen.
Also ich kenne eigentlich niemanden, der dafür war aus diesen Einrichtungen, aus diesem Umfeld. Weil alle eher auf diese Entwicklungschancen setzen, die so ein Gespräch, also die eine Auseinandersetzung auch online in sozialen Netzwerken darüber an Positiven bringt, gegenüber einem schieren Verbot, das von außen kommt, das nicht nachverzogen werden kann. Und ja, es ist halt verboten. Das heißt doch überhaupt nicht, dass sie das nicht machen. Das heißt doch überhaupt nicht, dass sie nicht irgendeinen Weg gesucht hat, um dahin zu kommen, wo man hin möchte.
Das könnte ja auch den Anreiz sozusagen noch verstärken.
Ja, definitiv. Also das nimmt diese Orientierung nicht raus. Und diese Orientierung auf Gangster-Possi, die diskutiert das gar nicht. Sondern die versucht, ein Riegel vorzuschieben und ist irgendwo auch eher hilflos und möchte sich damit eigentlich nicht näher befassen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein extrem dicker Klotz, den so diese ganze Jugendmedienarbeit, ich weiß gar nicht, was so der beste Überbegriff ist für den ganzen Kontext, aber so diese grundsätzliche Frage, Heranwachsende und Technologien. Jetzt haben wir viel Schlechtes gehört. Ich meine, siehst du auch irgendwo positive Entwicklungen und Chancen, die es zu ergreifen gilt?
Also Chancen sehe ich in dem, dass die Jugendlichen, laut der letzten Kim-Studie, Jim-Studie, Jugendliche in Medien, sich zu 70, 80, 90 Prozent ausdrücken. Also da auch in die Netzwerke reinzugehen, als Ansprechpartner präsent zu sein, als Medienpädagoge oder auch als Einrichtung. Und diese Weiterentwicklungsmöglichkeiten, die Peers bieten und die auf technischer Ebene Web2.0-Services bieten, zu nutzen, um Lerninhalte zu vermitteln, Bildung zu vermitteln, Freundschaften zu schließen, Unterhaltung zu haben. Da gibt es wesentlich mehr Möglichkeiten mit Netz als ohne, denke ich mal. Also das ist definitiv das Medium, das nicht nur die Berufsphäre bestimmt und bestimmen wird weiterhin, sondern wo viel über den Austausch und die Kommunikation möglich ist.
Und hast du nicht auch den Eindruck, ich meine, wir reden hier mit, wenn wir übers Internet reden, reden wir über eine Technologie, die so gefühlt 1995 so auf die Gesellschaft losgelassen wurde. Technisch gibt es das natürlich schon länger, aber so in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung fing das ja erst an. Und im Prinzip kann man auch die ersten fünf Jahre, glaube ich, erstmal weitgehend rausnehmen, wir haben das jetzt seit zehn Jahren. Und zehn Jahre, das ist irgendwie nicht viel. Handys haben wir jetzt seit 20 Jahren, das Telefon schon viel länger. Und es braucht halt immer so seine Zeit, bis sich eine Gesellschaft an so eine neue Technologie auch gewöhnt. Klar, es wird dann immer wieder gleich gestöhnt. Es würde ja immer alles so schnell gehen. Und kommt halt mal das eine drin, dann kommt schon wieder das nächste. Andererseits denke ich, kann man auch schon mal festhalten, so Internet, das geht jetzt nicht nächsten Montag wieder weg, sondern das bleibt so, das wird sich so aus sich selbst heraus entwickeln. Und ich habe so den Eindruck gewonnen, oder eigentlich auch, sagen wir mal viel mehr, ich habe eigentlich eher die Überzeugung aus meinem eigenen Erleben heraus, dass es eben, dass diese Medienkompetenz, die man sich mal so herbei wünscht, unter Umständen gar nicht so sehr hergestellt werden kann, sondern sich eigentlich selbst herstellt. Dass es eine Frage ist, wie eine Generation damit aufgewachsen ist, inwiefern alle anderen, mit denen ich zu tun habe, auch eben sich damit auseinandersetzen, sodass gerade unter Jugendlichen automatisch die Diskussion darüber kommt. So wie man sich mit allen anderen auseinandersetzt, die die anderen machen. Alle spielen Fußball, Fußball ist irgendwie ein Thema. Sexualität kommt sowieso irgendwann, wird darüber geredet, also haben das irgendwie auch alle natürlich da ihren eigenen Erfahrungsbereich, den sie machen. Technologie, Computer, Internet war halt bisher nicht so vertreten, aber das ändert sich jetzt auch, sodass auch der Umgang sich mit den sozialen Netzwerken etc. ändern kann. Ist das eine Illusion, wie ich das sehe, oder würde es zudem irgendwie was abgewinnen können?
Auf jeden Fall, also das ist überhaupt keine Illusion, sondern der Begriff von kinder- und jugendlichen Medienarbeit hat sich ja auch geändert. Also es kam auch von dem anfänglichen Begriff Medienkompetenz, der das auch, so wird er zumindest kritisiert, war zwar nie beabsichtigt, wird aber so kritisiert, technisch seinen Schwerpunkt hatte in der Vermittlung von Fähigkeiten, diese Maschine zu bedienen mittels Programme. Um Projekte herzustellen, kreative Art, ist ja auch alles löblich und wunderbar. Aber gerade weil es auch weiter um sich greift und diese Medienkonvergenz von Handy, Smartphone, Computer und mobilen Spielgeräten, die Lebensrealität auch bestimmt, ist man ja auch zu dem Begriff Medienbildung oder auch Media Literacy gekommen. Dieser Begriff ist größer und er umfasst einfach vielmehr diese Integration von verschiedenen technischen Services in den Alltag hinein. Und die Kinder und Jugendlichen, die damit aufwachsen, die entwickeln vielleicht in zwei Jahren was völlig anderes. Und Facebook ist gar nicht mehr so der Renner. Was jetzt schon größtenteils in der jungen Generation, oder bei jungen Erwachsenen auch schon der Fall ist, E-Mails, die haben keine E-Mail-Adresse, die reden über die sozialen Netzwerke. Und dann gibt es in drei bis fünf Jahren vielleicht wieder völlig andere Plattformen, über die alles abläuft. Das heißt, diese Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit ist wesentlich größer als bei den anderen Medien. Also Radio hat keine Ahnung, 30 bis 50 Jahre gebraucht, bis es sich durchgesetzt hat, Fernsehen noch mal 30 und Internet nur 20, oder jetzt halt mit den Netzwerken zehn. Diese Zeiträume werden kürzer und die Entwicklung ist wesentlich rasanter. Und die, die jetzt darin aufwachsen, die haben die Ideen, wie man neue Anwendungen entwickeln kann. Die werden, denke ich mal, schon alle netzbasiert sein, je nachdem, wie viel Internet wir dann haben. Vielleicht gibt es ja noch ein zweites oder sowas. Deshalb ist es überhaupt keine Illusion, sondern es ist eher so der Begriff dieses umfassenden Verständnisses, wie kann ich Medien welcher Art auch zu welchem Zweck einsetzen. Und die insgesamt gesellschaftliche Tendenz, also zumindest die bei Jugendlichen geht hin, technische Gadgets einzusetzen, immer mehr und immer stärker. Und das denke ich mal wird auch jetzt bis auf die Erscheinung, dass es Jugendliche gibt, die sich ja völlig rausklinken, so weitergehen.
Und wie siehst du das so mit der Technologie und den Schulen selbst? Also ich meine, wir haben die ganze Zeit immer so die Schule und dann kommt so die Technologie von außen und man muss irgendwie damit umgehen. Aber ich meine, Technologie kann ja auch den ganzen Schulprozess, Erziehungsprozess selbst auch maßgeblich beeinflussen. Und so aus deiner Erfahrung heraus, wie unterrichtet wird, wie Inhalte vermittelt werden sollen. Siehst du das auch, dass das Arbeiten mit Computern oder auch Tablets, Smartphones, also mit den Geräten, die man vielleicht sowieso schon hat, dass die mehr in den Unterricht integriert werden könnten, dass das auch zum guten beitragen könnte? Ich will das mal ganz zurückhalten und vorsichtig formulieren. Ich habe da jetzt auch nicht so die allumfassende Technikgläubigkeit oder möchte das unterstützen.
Die vorgehend so vorsichtige Art kann ich dann nur unterstützen. Ja, weil, denke ich mal, die Konzepte in den Schulen sich auch ein bisschen ändern müssen. Also was jetzt fast schon ein Quantensprung ist, das ist die doch weitergehende Einführung von Whiteboards an den Schulen. Das heißt, Ende der Kreidezeit wird propagiert. Es werden Whiteboards installiert. Mit denen kann man natürlich mehr machen. Mit denen kann man Dateien aufrufen, die eine Woche vorher bearbeitet wurden. Mit denen kann man per Touchpad arbeiten.
Achso, du meinst so digitale Whiteboards.
Achso, stimmt, das gibt es ja auch nicht anders.
Jaja.
Die werden angeschafft, die Schulen kaufen sich die Sachen und sagen, ey, wir sind modern, das finde ich toll. Man kann auf dieser digitalen Ebene halt wesentlich die Bearbeitungsfunktion einer Kreidetafel überschreiten, definitiv innerhalb kürzester Zeit. Das Konzept des Frontalunterrichts ändert sich dadurch aber nicht unbedingt. Und insofern Technologie eingeführt wird, die Partizipation ermöglicht, denke ich, man müssen sich auch die Lernkonzepte in Schulen in Richtung Partizipation öffnen. Also Lernmanagementsysteme einführen in Grundschulen, das sind Ideen. Ich weiß ganz genau, die Elternschaft kreist auf, was sollen denn die jetzt dann auch noch permanent die ganze Zeit vom Computer sitzen. Worum es überhaupt nicht geht, wo Einzelteile integriert werden sollen in den normalen Schulalltag, aber wo auch dann teilweise Frontalunterrichte aufgelöst werden, weil es diese Art von Wissensvermittlung mit dieser Technologie nicht unbedingt bringt. Das knirscht, das passt nicht unbedingt zusammen. Also insofern ist dieser technische Fortschritt auch ein Geburtshelfer für andere Ideen von Unterrichtskonzepten. Das ist so ein bisschen der Fortschritt, der sich da langwälzt und irgendwann dann doch mal dazu führt, mehr Technologie einzusetzen. Andererseits ist es wirklich auch leider Gottes eine Generationsfrage, weil es viel zu wenig aus den älteren Generationen gibt, die sich mit dieser Technologie oder auch mit Computern überhaupt auseinandersetzen möchten. Erstens. Zweitens. Dann auch noch überlegen, wollen, inwiefern sie das für ihren Unterricht einsetzen. Beide Aspekte sind für sie, sagen wir mal, wohlwollend weit weg und das lassen sie einfach gerne so. Weil die letzten, keine Ahnung, 15 Jahre kriegen sie auch noch so rum. Da müssen sie sich damit nicht auseinandersetzen. Jüngere Lehrer und Lehrerinnen, die gibt es auch in Berlin, die werden auch immer mehr, die überlegen und die setzen die auch einfach selbstverständlich ein. Die kriegen von den Direktorien auch gerne das okay, weil komischerweise die Direktorien, zumindest von den Grundschulen, die ich auch hier abgeklappert habe, immer bereit sind, da zu kooperieren, Projekte zu machen, Computerräume aufzubauen. Es geht eher darum, die Lehrer und Lehrerinnen zu finden, die das konkret umsetzen und die Ideen haben. Es ist mehr Arbeit, wenn man sich damit nicht auskennt. Lehrer, die sich einarbeiten, müssen das ganz oft privat finanzieren und privat machen. Das heißt, es geht Geld und Zeit da rein. Und das sind Hemmschuhe. Das sind definitiv keine entwicklungsfördernden Elemente, sondern die blockieren. Und insofern sich das jemand privat ans Bein bindet, was gemacht wird, wunderbar. Aber oft ist es halt eben nicht der Fall. Und dann sind es die Jüngeren, die mit den Laptops in die Schule kommen und die sagen, wo ist denn jetzt hier der Netzwerkeanschluss? Also da treffen dann so ein bisschen Welten aufeinander, die passen da nicht unbedingt. Die Schulen sind hinterher leider langsam. Das hängt auch nicht unbedingt nur an den Schulen, sondern auch an Entwicklungsplänen, die das Fördern so vorsichtig formuliert auch wieder mit Geld und Finanzierung im Hintergrund. Aber also das Einzige, was hilft, ist dann ein Direktorium oder auch ein Kollegium, die dann sagen, okay, wir wollen das, wir setzen es auch um, dann haben sie die Mehrarbeit am Hacken.
Aber jetzt mal unabhängig von der Mehrarbeit. Ich meine, dass das dann für den Einzelnen immer eine Belastung sein kann, das sehe ich ja auch. Andererseits denke ich, ist das auch die Gelegenheit für wirklich innovativ denkende Lehrer dann auch zur, naja, Profilierung ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit gegriffen. Aber ich meine, wenn ich in einem Bereich arbeite, dann will ich da auch irgendwie was bewegen. Ich denke, das geht auch sicherlich vielen Lehrern so. Das ist natürlich dann auch immer die Möglichkeit, dann eben auch die Lernkonzepte nach vorne zu bringen, weil man ja nur nicht so arbeiten will wie vor 50 Jahren und das macht ja eigentlich auch keine Ahnung. Auch die Schule macht Fortschritte, auch wenn man ja immer wieder vorwirft, in der Vergangenheit zu leben. Aber wenn man sich die Vergangenheit von vor 50 Jahren anschaut, dann denke ich, da ist halt nicht mehr so sehr viel von übrig. Wenn ich mir jetzt eben angucke, wie so die ganzen Netzwerke mit reinkommen, wie auch die Schüler das immer mehr integrieren, das bietet ja dann langfristig auch Perspektiven im Hinblick darauf, dass man eben, was weiß ich, diese sozialen, vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt die sozialen Netzwerke von heute, aber vielleicht so die sozialen Netzwerkstrukturen oder die technischen Möglichkeiten von morgen oder übermorgen, dass die eben auch Teil des Lernprozesses wären, dass man E-Mail mit benutzt, dass man solche Sachen wie Diskussions-Mailing-Listen, Sharing-Bereiche für Dateien, mal ganz einfach gedacht, auch Teil der Arbeits-, also Lernwelt mit nutzt und dabei aber auch vor allem die Eltern auch mehr mit einbezieht. Weil das ist ja immer so eine Klage, die Eltern werfen jetzt hier irgendwie die Kinder ab und dann wird von uns an der Schule erwartet, dass die jetzt irgendwie weitergebildet werden. Das findet dann irgendwie nicht statt, weil vor allem die Eltern eben nichts dazu beitragen, und dann können sie ja irgendwie auch nichts machen. Auf der anderen Seite mag es auch viele Eltern geben, die damit auch gar nicht so glücklich sind und sehr viel lieber so einen Link auch in diese Schule sehen würden, den aber so nicht haben, weil es eben auch diese einfache Partizipation so nicht gibt. Aber wenn man irgendwie an dem, was weiß ich, würde ich jetzt wissen, was meinem Kind in dieser Schule, in diesem Jahr, in den jeweiligen Fächern auch konkret an Wissen vermittelt werden soll. Wenn ich an die Materialien einfach so rankomme, dass ich die ganzen Lern- und Textbücher allein schon hätte, einfach genau weiß, was auch gerade im Unterricht vermittelt werden soll, was dann gegebenenfalls zu Hause auch nachbearbeitet, nachgefragt, nach gelernt, unterstützt werden kann, hinterfragt werden kann. Das wäre doch eigentlich auch ein interessanter Weg, oder nicht?
Also ich denke, das ist auch der Weg. Also wie du das aufgezeichnet hast, wäre das für mich in den nächsten drei bis fünf Jahren den Weg, den ich als Senatsverwaltung einschlagen würde, nämlich zu sagen, wir ermöglichen es an den Schulen, Lernplattformen einzusetzen, oder wir gehen in die Netzwerke rein. Also den Einsatz von Web 2.0-Sachen, auch gerade in sozialen Netzwerken, der wird ja breit diskutiert. Also man muss immer wirklich gucken, passt dieses Netzwerk jetzt auch auf dieses Lernsetting, das ich aufbauen möchte. Dann ist es vielleicht eher nicht ein soziales Netzwerk, sondern es ist vielleicht eher ein Wiki. Dann muss ich aber die Möglichkeit haben, innerhalb und außerhalb der Schule darauf zuzugreifen. Oder es ist eine Lernplattform wie Moodle oder Ilias oder auch andere. Diese Perspektive, Schulmaterialien auch in möglichst freien Formaten natürlich auf diesen Lernplattformen zu platzieren, halte ich für eine der Möglichkeiten, das für die Eltern zu öffnen und dieses Interesse von den Kindern und Jugendlichen aus den Schulen mit diesen Medien wirklich auch zu arbeiten. Und das ist auch da. Das ist nicht nur das Spielen und Unterhalten sein wollen. Aufzugreifen und auch in diese Richtung zu fördern. Der Punkt ist dann natürlich, was ich bei Altermedienabenden oft merke, dass die Eltern auch erstmal darüber informiert werden wollen, wo ihre Kinder eigentlich sind, was sie eigentlich machen. Die müssen das auch wissen. Die müssen wissen, welche Möglichkeiten und welche Gefahren und welche Chancen. Aber auch hat Facebook, hat Twitter, hat E-Mail verkehrt oder sonst irgendwas. Das heißt, da muss noch ganz viel Aufklärung passieren. Und was natürlich nochmal um den Anfang des Gesprächs zu rekapitulieren toll ist, sind Leute, die als Eltern auch gerne hinter technischen Entwicklungen hinterhergehen und sagen, Mensch, ich guck mir das mal an. Die haben komischerweise ganz oft gar nicht so dieses Gefühl, ich muss irgendwas verbieten, ich muss irgendwas einschränken, sondern versuchen, selber einen gesunden Umgang damit reinzukriegen. Ja, sonst wären sie auch an dem Abend nicht auf dem Elternabend, sondern auch vor dem Bildschirm, sondern sie sind beim Elternabend, sie sind engagiert und versuchen, diese beiden Seiten, ich will das Medium nutzen und ich will aber trotzdem irgendwie meine geistige und psychische Gesundheit aufrechterhalten, die ich von meinen Kindern auch in Einklang zu kriegen. Solche Wege zu fördern ist definitiv angesagt. Und da haben wir sehr viel Services, die wir nutzen könnten. Und die Schulen könnten auch mal auf solche Ideen kommen. Kommen sie aber nicht, weil die auch in ihrem eigenen Denken ganz oft noch gefangen sind. Das soll jetzt nicht dagegen gehen, dass Schulen sind böse und haben keine Ideen und Fantasie, sondern da stehen oft wirklich tatkräftige Hemmnisse im Weg, die erst mal überwunden werden müssen. Aber diese Möglichkeiten, die wir haben, die können alle eingesetzt werden. Ich kann alle nur ermutigen, macht es einfach, probiert es aus. Es gibt genug Sandboxes, wo nichts passieren kann, um Sachen auszuprobieren, Modellinstallationen müssen nicht auf Servern laufen, die können auch gehostet werden. Das ist relativ einfach machbar.
Ja, Bernd, jetzt haben wir ja einiges durch, kann man jetzt hier auch, glaube ich, langsam mal einen Punkt machen. Falls wir nicht noch etwas ganz furchtbar Wichtiges vergessen haben, haben wir bestimmt, aber fällt uns jetzt nicht ein. Ja, vielen Dank für die Ausführung, war vieles auch, vor allem erstmal Gedankenanregungen, denke ich, was sie auch gezeigt hat. Es gibt keine einfachen Antworten, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Menge Fragen, die mal aufgerufen werden müssen. So auch hier bei Chaosradio Express in dieser Ausgabe, aber vielleicht auch in der Zukunft. Mal gucken. Und ja, mir bleibt nochmal Danke zu sagen.
Gerne.
Und danke auch fürs Zuhören, wie immer. Das war's. Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 178. Bis bald auf diesem Kanal.